OTHERS CONVENES THE JOINT
COMMITTEE ON RULES OF A
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
ASSEMBLY.
ON JUNE TWENTY FIFTH.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN OF THE PURPOSE
OF THIS HEARING IS TRUE. TO
REVIEW RECEIVE RECOMMENDATIONS
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE ON SEXUAL
HARASSMENT PREVENTION RESPONSE
[inaudible]
THIS.
THIS HEARING ARE REPRESENTS A
MILESTONE IN AN EFFORT TO BEGAN
WITH THE WE SEVEN OFF LETTER
THAT WAS RELEASED ON OCTOBER
SEVENTEENTH OF LAST YEAR
[inaudible]
HIGHLIGHTING [inaudible]
CONCERNS OBJECTIONS REPORTS
[inaudible]
OF THIS STATE CAPITOL THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AS AN ENVIRONMENT
WHICH A BUSINESS WAS CONDUCTED
[inaudible]
AND CONDUCT THAT.
WAS NOT IN KEEPING WITH THE
PRINCIPLES OF THE LEGISLATURE.
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRACY CIVIL
TREATMENT OF ONE ANOTHER AND ANY
SAID IN MUCH LESS A PROFESSIONAL
LAWMAKING SETTING.
AND AS A CONSEQUENCE THIS
HEARING IS ACTUALLY A TESTAMENT
AND A COMPLIMENT --
TO THE BRAVE PEOPLE WHO
PROTESTED THAT PROCESS IN THAT
LETTER.
AND THE MONTHS.
OF THAT FOLLOWED --
THE HEARING IS ALSO NOTABLE IN
THE HISTORY OF THE LEGISLATURE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
AS INCONTESTABLE LEE A HISTORIC
[inaudible]
BICAMERAL [inaudible]
BIPARTISAN UNDERTAKING. TO LOOK
AT HOW TO SUPPORT THE WORK OF
THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE.
IN A WAY THAT UPHOLDS THE VALUES
THAT WE HOLD DEAR IN THE
PEOPLE'S HOUSE --
AND I CAN ATTEST THAT HAS BEEN
AN OUTSTANDING DELIVERED OF
EFFORT.
AS I'VE SAID THROUGH VIRTUALLY
ALL OF THE BABIES OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND HAVE SEEN THE HIGH LEVEL
ENGAGEMENT BY EVERY MEMBER OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
THE GIVE AND TAKE.
THE WILLINGNESS [inaudible]
TO ASK QUESTIONS OF AND
SUPPORTED BY OUTSTANDING STAFF
[inaudible] TO MAKE EACH YEAR
AND AND A MODERATION LEADS TO
THE NEXT HEARING IN ITS
DELIBERATIONS --
AND OF SINCE LAST FALL THIS
ISSUE OF HOW DOES A LEGISLATIVE
BODY.
EMPOWER IN THE CONSTITUTION
DIRECT RESPONSIBLE DAY ELECTORS
TO PUT THE LAWMAKERS THEIR NONE
THE LESS ESTABLISHED THE RIGHT
TONE AT THE TOP. TO ESTABLISH
THE WORKPLACE SAID IN THAT ALL
CAN DO OUR WORK ON BEHALF OF THE
CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
A THAT.
WAS SEEN AS ESSENTIAL TO
ESTABLISHING THE CAP WAS A SAFE
AND SECURE WORKPLACE.
AND REALLY IT'S THE WORK OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE TO THERE'S DIED
DEEPLY INTO THIS ISSUE OF WHAT
ARE THE TOOLS AND THE
MECHANISMS.
TWO STEPS A RIGHT TOLD AT THE
TOP SAFE AND SECURE FOR ALL
WORKERS --
TODAY WE WILL RECEIVE THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT COME OUT OF
THAT DELIBERATION.
THE FIVE HEARINGS JUST REVIEW
WERE JANUARY TWENTY FOURTH
FEBRUARY FIFTEENTH MARCH SIXTH
MARCH FOURTEENTH AND THEN ON
JUNE EIGHTEENTH.
AND OF COURSE WE ARE INDEBTED TO
THE CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE --
LAURA FRIEDMAN ASSEMBLY WOMAN
CHAIR HOLLY MITCHELL VICE CHAIR
CENTER HOLLY MITCHELL PARDON ME.
COLLEAGUES ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN
DALLY ELOISE GOMEZ REYES AND
MARIE WALDRON AND THE SENATE.
A MINORITY LEADER PAT BATES
CONNIE LABOR AND JOHN MORLOCK --
AND DOES SO TODAY WILL RECEIVE
THEIR RECOMMENDATIONS AND WITH
THAT I'D LIKE TO TURN TO MY VICE
CHAIR SENATOR ANTHONY CANNELLA
[inaudible]
LOW.
CAN WE ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY HERE --
SENATOR CANNELLA HERE
[inaudible]
CALDERON [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
CERVANTES CUNNINGHAM HERE
[inaudible]
DALLEY [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
MAYES HERE THIS AREA
[inaudible]
RENDON [inaudible]
SALAS [inaudible]
WALDRON [inaudible]
SENATOR ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BERRYHILL [inaudible]
LARA [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL.
MONNING HERE MORLOCK
[inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
HERE [inaudible]
SKINNER.
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
AND I TURNED OUT.
TO TURNOUT OF VICE CHAIR OF
CANNELLA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THAT
SEEMS SO THE LAST FEW MONTHS
THAT WE'VE BEEN GROUND ZERO FOR
THE ME TOO MOVEMENT.
NOT NECESSARILY SOMETHING WE
SHOULD BE PROUD OF BUT WE SHOULD
SEE THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ENSURE THAT THE WRONGS OF THE
PAST DON'T ONCE AGAIN BECOME OUR
FUTURE.
WE NEED TO MAKE THIS RIGHT
PROTECT THOSE WHO MAY FACE THIS
TOMORROW I'M ENCOURAGED BY THE
RECOMMENDATIONS MADE LAST WEEK
BY THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
THAT THIS PROCESS CAN BE
ADMINISTERED FAIRLY SWIFTLY AND
THOUGHTFULLY.
THAT'S WHAT THE PUBLIC STAFF AND
MEMBERS EXPECT AND DESERVE.
WELL I THINK SENATOR MITCHELL
ASSEMBLY WOMAN FRIEDMAN OF THE
OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
STAFF YOUR DILIGENT EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE HEAD ON WELL
MY PRIMARY CONCERNS IS TO ENSURE
THAT ANY PROCESS WE PUT INTO
PLACE IS CONSISTENT.
NOT ONLY BETWEEN THE SENATE AND
THE ASSEMBLY BUT CONSISTENCY
AMONG ALL THOSE INVOLVED WHETHER
THE SITUATION INVOLVES A JUNIOR
STAFFER.
OR MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATURE.
THERE SHOULD BE A NOT BE ANY
PERCEPTION OR REALITY OF
FAVORITISM OR BIAS.
CHANGING OUR POLICY TO ADDRESS
SHORTCOMINGS IS A GOOD START BUT
CHANGING THE CULTURE IS THE
ULTIMATE GOAL TALK IS CHEAP.
THE CURRENT CULTURE AND POLITICS
RIGHT NOW WHICH IS A CHARGED
ENVIRONMENT.
SO PROVING COMMUNICATIONS
CIVILITY AND RESPECT IS A
DEFINITE CHALLENGE BUT I KNOW UP
TO THANK YOU AS CHAIRMAN
[inaudible]
VERY GOOD.
ALL WITH FATS I WOULD INVITE --
CHAIR LAURA FRIEDMAN OF THE
ASSEMBLY AND VICE CHAIR HOLLY
MITCHELL OF THE SENATE.
TO GO TO OUR DIETS AND COMMENCE
YOUR PRESENTATION.
OF YOUR SUB COMMITTEE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
AND CLIMATE SURVEY RESULTS.
AND AGAIN WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK THESE PAST MONTHS
[inaudible]
IT WENT.
THANK YOU OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
--
BEFORE IF WE BEGIN I JUST WANTED
TO MAKE A FEW THANK YOUS MYSELF
THAT'S OKAY.
I WANT TO FIRST OF ALL THANK ALL
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
THEIR MANY MANY MONTHS OF VERY
VERY HARD WORK ON THIS DIFFICULT
TOPIC.
I WANT TO THANK SPEAKER RENDON
PRO TEM ATKINS FOR THEIR AMAZING
LEADERSHIP AND SUPPORT FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING BOTH LEADERS OF
BOTH HOUSES.
WERE UNEQUIVOCAL IN SAYING THAT
THEY WANTED TO HAVE CALIFORNIA
LEAD THE NATION IN CRAFTING THE
MOST COMPREHENSIVE.
AND PROTECTIVE SEXUAL HARASSMENT
POLICIES IN THE NATION AND I
THINK THAT WE'VE MADE A BIG STEP
TOWARDS DOING THAT TODAY AND
IT'S BECAUSE OF THEIR LEADERSHIP
AND OF COURSE CHAIRMAN COOLIES
LEADERSHIP AND SUPPORT HAS BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL.
I WANT TO THANK THE MANY MEMBERS
OF WE SAID ENOUGH WHO WERE THE
ONES WHO REALLY BEGAN US ON THIS
PATH THEIR BRAVERY AND STANDING
UP AND TELLING THEIR STORIES.
CAN'T BE UNDERSTATED AND THEY'RE
THE REASON THAT WE'RE HERE
TODAY.
I'M ALSO ALL OF THE STAFFERS
FROM FROM THE LEGISLATURE WHO
SENT.
THEIR TESTIMONY IN ANONYMOUSLY
WHO CAME TO THE COMMITTEE
MEETINGS MANY OF THEM CAME TO MY
OFFICE STOP ME IN THE HALL AND
IT'S NOT EASY FOR A STAFFER TO
PULL A MEMBER SIDE AND MAKE
SUGGESTIONS LIKE THAT AND TALK
ABOUT THEIR OWN EXPERIENCES AND
I WANT TO COMMEND THEM. FOR NOT
JUST THEIR BRAVERY BUT THEIR
COMMITMENT TO HELPING THEIR
COLLEAGUES --
AND THEN SUPPORTING THEM.
GRANT WHO WAS COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR HIS VERY THOUGHTFUL GUIDANCE
--
AND DILIGENCE AS WELL AS MY
CHIEF ALISON ROTH WHO ALSO --
WAS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND THIS
PROCESS I WANT I THINK THE
ASSEMBLY RULES COMMITTEE STAFF
OUR CHIEF ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER
DEBRA GRAVERT DEPUTY
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER LEO LOPEZ
HUMAN RESOURCES DIRECTOR TASHA
CHERRY. FOR EIGHT MONTHS THEY'VE
REALLY BEEN UNDER A MICROSCOPE
AND IT'S BEEN DIFFICULT FOR
THEM.
AND THEY HAVE THROUGH ALL OF IT
MAINTAIN THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
PROFESSIONALISM AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY COMPASSION AND
CONCERN FOR THE EMPLOYEES THAT
THEY REPRESENT.
AND THERE ARE REAL TESTIMONY TO
WHAT WE CAN ACCOMPLISH AND I
KNOW THAT BILL BE ABLE TO GUIDE
THIS NEW POLICY IN THE DIRECTION
THAT IT NEEDS TO GO BECAUSE THEY
ARE TRUE PROFESSIONALS.
AND I'VE SAID BEFORE WE NEED
MORE PEOPLE LIKE THEM --
AS WE BEEF UP THIS POLICY IN
CRATER NEW DEPARTMENT AND I WANT
TO THANK THEM FOR ALL OF THEIR
WORK -- I
WANT TO THANK THE SENATE ARE
SENATE PARTNERS A VICE CHAIR
MITCHELL OF THE HOUSES DON'T
OFTEN WORK TOGETHER IN THIS
FASHION.
I DIDN'T KNOW THAT IS I'M A
FRESHMAN BUT I'VE LEARNED THAT
SOMETIMES NAVIGATING THOSE
WATERS ON TAKES A LITTLE BIT OF
TIME BUT EVERYBODY WORK TOGETHER
EXTREMELY WELL.
I'M BRINGING THEIR ISSUES
FORWARD AND I THINK THAT BECAUSE
OF THE BICAMERAL NATURE OF THIS
COMMITTEE WE HAVE A MUCH
STRONGER POLICY WITH A LOT MORE.
PERSPECTIVES REALLY HAVE BEEN ON
THE BEEN TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION.
AND LASTLY BEFORE I MOVE NOW TO
THE ACTUAL PRESENTATION I WANNA
SAY THAT ALTHOUGH CALIFORNIA I
BELIEVE IS LEADING THE WAY AND
I'VE LOOKED AT WHAT OTHER STATES
ARE DOING AND I DON'T THINK
THERE'S ANYBODY OUT THERE THAT'S
DONE AS COMPREHENSIVE A WAS A
FRAMEWORK.
WE'RE NOT GONNA WALK OUT OF THIS
MEETING TODAY BEING ABLE TO SAY
THAT WE SOLVE SEXUAL HARASSMENT
THE LEGISLATURE.
OR EVEN THAT WE HAVE THE PERFECT
POLICY IN PLACE I THINK THAT
WE'VE DONE IT IN A A REALLY --
COMPREHENSIVE JOB OF TRYING TO
ALL OF THE IF FOR ASPECTS OF
POLICY THAT IMPACTS SEXUAL
HARASSMENT OTHER TYPES OF
WORKPLACE DISCRIMINATION.
BUT THIS IS GOING TO BE AN
ONGOING KIND OF PROJECT WE'RE
GOING TO PUT SOMETHING IN THE
PLACE WE'RE GOING.
TO KIND OF PUSH IT IN DIFFERENT
DIRECTIONS AS WE START TO BUILD
OUT THAT POLICY FROM THIS
FRAMEWORK WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
DO A LOT OF EVALUATION OVER TIME
AND PROBABLY QUITE A LOT OF FINE
TUNING.
AS IT SHOULD BE.
BECAUSE THIS IS ABOUT CULTURE
CHANGE OR NOT IT'S NOT ABOUT
PUTTING A OF VOTING ON A SET OF
POLICIES AND SAYING THAT YOU'RE
DONE.
IT'S ABOUT STARTING THE
BEGINNING OF A LONGER PROCESS
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING
TODAY SO IT'S GOING TO TAKE
DILIGENCE IT'S GOING TO TAKE A
VALUATION.
AND CERTAINLY IT'S GOING TO TAKE
INTROSPECTION AND A LOT OF
EFFORT ON EVERYONE'S BEHALF
STARTING WITH OUR OWN OFFICES.
NOW TO THE POWER POINT
PRESENTATION.
ARM AS THE CHAIR SAID UGH
CHAIRMAN SAID WE HAVE HAD FIVE
HEARINGS INCLUDING ONE THAT WAS
JOHN AB PLUS ONE THAT WAS JUST
ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE SINCE
JANUARY.
WE'VE HEARD WRITTEN TESTIMONY IN
REPORTS BOTH ONLINE AND IN
PERSON.
WE CONDUCTED EXTREMELY VALUABLE
WORKPLACE CLIMATE SURVEY THAT
WE'RE GOING TO TALK TO ABOUT --
A WE HAVE FOLLOWED UP WITH MANY
HEARINGS --
AND BICAMERAL AND BIPARTISAN
LEADERSHIP I AND WE HELD A
HEARING ON THE DRAFT
RECOMMENDATIONS JUST LAST WEEK.
SO IT'S BEEN A VERY
COMPREHENSIVE PROCESS WITH A LOT
OF DISCUSSIONS A LEADING UP TO
THIS DAY.
I'M A WITHOUT I'D LIKE TO TURN
TO VICE CHAIR HOLY MITCHELL FOR
ANY OPENING REMARKS AND TO TALK
TO US ABOUT THE CLIMATE SURVEY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MISTER
CHAIR I COLLEAGUES --
THIS MORNING ON KQED AS OUR
DRIVE INTO THAT CAPPED Y. CAUGHT
THE TAIL END OF IT INTERESTING
REPORT --
REPORT.
THE INTERVIEW WAS --
BEING CONDUCTED WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF MALES COLLEGE AND
SHE WAS TALKING ABOUT A SEXUAL
HARASSMENT REPORT THAT THEY'VE
COMPLETED ON CAMPUS IN THE AND
IF YOU ARE WAS SUGGESTING THAT
THE OUTCOME OF THE REPORT WAS IT
--
VERY POSITIVE.
THE DID APPEAR AS IF THEY'VE
MADE MUCH PROGRESS IN THEIR
ATTEMPT TO A DEAL WITH THE
ISSUE.
AND SHE MADE THE STATEMENT WHICH
I THOUGHT WAS QUITE PROFOUND AND
CERTAINLY APPLIES TO US.
AND HER COMMENT WAS THAT THE
CLIMATE IN THE WORKPLACE.
IS AS IMPORTANT AS THE WORK
THAT'S BEING CONDUCTED THERE.
AND SO IN THAT YOU'VE HEARD FROM
THE CHAIR ALL OF THE PROPHECIES%
WE'VE ALL GONE THROUGH OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL MONTHS.
I THINK WHAT'S IMPORTANT FOR
SALTERTON REMEMBER IS THIS IS AN
H. OUR POLICY.
THAT WILL GOVERN.
HOW WE AS EMPLOYERS AND
EMPLOYEES INTERACT WITH ONE
ANOTHER [inaudible] TO THAT.
POINT WE ENGAGED ARE IN A
CLIMATE SURVEY I THINK FOR THE
FIRST TIME FIND.
REMEMBER CORRECTLY FROM --
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE RULES
PROVIDING INFORMATION PROVIDING
INFORMATION THE FIRST TIME THE
LEGISLATURE'S CONDUCTED AN
OFFICIAL CLIMATE SURVEY WE ARE
ASKING.
EMPLOYEES BOTH THE DISTRICT
OFFICES COMMITTEE OFFICES
CAPITOL OFFICES AS WELL AS
VOLUNTEERS AND INTERNS. TO TALK
TO US ABOUT THEIR EXPERIENCE AS
AN EMPLOYEE WORKING FOR THE
LEGISLATURE.
WE ENGAGE SEE ARE A FIRM THAT
HAS --
EXTENSIVE EXPERIENCE IN
CONDUCTING CLIMATE SURVEYS AND
WE JUMPED WE LAUNCH THIS
PROCESS.
LEGISLATURE OR WERE ALSO INVITED
TO PARTICIPATE.
THIS IS A HIGH LEVEL FOUR FIVE
FLY --
SUMMARY OF SOME OF THE KEY
FINDINGS MOST OF WHICH I HAVE TO
TELL YOU AND YOUR FELLOW
COLLEAGUE WERE REALLY GOOD NEWS.
THE INFORMATION IS BEING ROLLED
OUT TO YOUR CHIEF OF STAFF AND
WE ARE HOPING THAT YOUR SHE THE
STAFF WILL TALK ABOUT.
THE RESULTS WITH YOUR EMPLOYEES
BECAUSE IT REALLY IS THEIR DATA
AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THEY SEE
WHERE THEY FIT IN IN TERMS OF
THE OVERALL CLIMATE.
OF THE LEGISLATURE AS A WHOLE.
SO THE NUMBER OF ELIGIBLE
PARTICIPANTS YOU'LL SEE WAS
TWENTY SIX HUNDRED ROUGHLY WE
LEARNED FROM THE VENDOR THAT FOR
PARTICULAR FOR A FIRST TIME
SURVEY OF THE SKYLINE.
OUR EXPECTATIONS SHOULD BE
ANYWHERE FROMBY THE THIRTY
SIXTH OF 49% RETURN RATE.
AND YOU SEE --
THE LEGISLATURE AS A WHOLE FELL
RIGHT IN WHERE WE SHOULD EXPECT
TO FALL.
NEXT LIVE.
THE NEXT TWO SLIDES ARE GOING TO
FOCUS ON WHAT THEY IDENTIFIED AS
OUR REAL ORGANIZATIONAL STRENGTH
--
YOU KNOW WE ARE TO SUBMIT THE
SURVEY ITSELF TO TAKE ABOUT TEN
MINUTES --
MISTER COOLEY WAS FRIEDMAN AND I
WERE INVOLVED ALONG WITH
ASSEMBLY THE SENATE RULES STAFF
IN TERMS OF WORKING WITH THE
VENDOR TO REALLY MAKE SURE THAT
THE QUESTIONS WERE HUMANE TO OUR
EXPERIENCE IN THE LEGISLATURE.
THE VENDOR HAD WORKED WITH
GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES PREVIOUSLY
BUT NEVER LEGISLATURE SO SOME OF
THE QUESTIONS HAVE TO BE --
CHANGE AND ALTER TO NEW WANTS TO
MAKE IT RELEVANT WE DON'T
CELEBRATE ACT HERE WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE QUESTIONS
WERE.
TO SO EMPLOYEES WOULD NOW THAT
IT.
AND SOME OF THE REALLY GOOD NEWS
AS YOU'LL SEE EMPLOYEES ARE
SATISFIED WITH THEIR WORK DUTIES
THAT ARE COMMITTED TO THEIR WORK
IN PUBLIC SERVICE 70% ARE
SATISFIED.
JOB DUTIES DECIDED AS THE NUMBER
ONE REASON EMPLOYEES ARE STAYING
78% OF EMPLOYEES INDICATE THE
INTENT TO REMAIN EMPLOYED BUT
THE LEGISLATURE.
AND EMPLOYEES WERE SATISFIED
WITH THEIR HEALTH PLANS AND
BELIEVE THE LEGISLATURE IS
COMMITTED TO DELIVERING HIGH
QUALITY SERVICE TO THE PUBLIC
[inaudible]
NEXT SLIDE.
THIS FOR ME I THINK I AS A
FORMER STAFF.
ALBEIT DECADES AGO AS WELL AS A
MEMBER AND AS AN EMPLOYER.
ARE THESE RESULT RESULTS I THINK
WITH THE MOST --
AYE OPENING AND REWARDING
RESULTS INDICATE STRONG
RELATIONSHIPS WITH COWORKERS AND
LEADERS 83% OF EMPLOYEES ARE
ENGAGED BY THEIR CO WORKERS. 70%
OF EMPLOYEES ARE ENGAGED BY THE
DIRECT IMMEDIATE STEPS
SUPERVISOR AND OVER 80% OF
EMPLOYEES BELIEVE THEIR
SUPERVISOR IS TRUSTWORTHY CARING
AND LISTENS TO THEIR IDEAS.
I THINK THIS WAS SIGNIFICANT AND
ALSO IN TERMS OF THE QUESTION WE
WERE CLEAR --
THAT IT WAS THE ON YOUR MOST
DIRECT SUPERVISOR.
SO THAT WAS THE CHIEF OF STAFF
RESPONDING THEY'RE RESPONDING
WITH REGARD TO THE LEGISLATOR IF
IT WAS A LET JAY.
THEY WERE RESPONDING THEY THAT
WE DEFINE TO THEIR SUPERVISOR
WAS BASED ON THEIR SPECIFIC
POSITION SO ON LEGISLATOR SHOULD
NOT ASSUME THAT ALL OF THOSE
COMMENTS WHERE --
TRICK THAT IT US WHAT WAS ON
POWERFUL ABOUT THAT AS WE TALK
ABOUT THE NEED TO CHANGE CULTURE
IS RECOGNIZING.
HOW FOLKS FEEL ABOUT THEIR
COWORKERS THEY SPEND MORE TIME
WITH EACH OTHER THAN THEY DO
WITH US?
AS WELL AS PERSON THAT THEY HAVE
TO RELY ON TO GET.
INSTITUTIONAL INFORMATION AND
WHO THEY REPORT CONCERNS IN THE
WORKPLACE TO WHICH IS THEIR
SUPERVISOR AND THAT'S THE PERSON
THAT THEY FEEL LISTENS TO THEM
THAT THEY FEEL LESS TRUSTWORTHY
IN CARES ABOUT THEM.
SO FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF
TAKING A TEMPERATURE CHECK OF
THE CULTURE OF THE INSTITUTION
RECOGNIZING THAT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF OUR EMPLOYEES FEEL
GOOD ABOUT THEIR RELATIONSHIP
WITH THEIR DIRECT SUPERVISOR.
IS A REAL STRENGTH NEXT SLIDE.
WE NOW MOVE INTO ORGANIZATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES WITH REGARD TO THE
STRENGTH WE ASK THE VENDOR TO
GIVE US A SENSE OF KIND OF WHERE
WE FAIL ON THE SPECTRUM OF YOU
KNOW 70% THAT WOULD BE A CITY IS
THAT GOOD OR NOT --
AND SO THEY GAVE US IN THE FULL
REPORT WHICH YOU CAN HAVE ACCESS
TO KIND OF WHERE WE FAIL IN
TERMS OF OUR RATING.
AND COMPARED TO OTHER GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATIONS AND AGAIN IN THE
AREAS OF OUR STRENGTH WE READ
THE HIGH PERFORMING IN.
NOW WITH REGARD TO
ORGANIZATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
CLEARLY BASED ON THE NUMBERS YOU
SEE THESE ARE AREAS WHERE WE
HAVE TO FOCUS AND TARGET OUR
EFFORTS SO WE CAN SEE SOME
IMPROVEMENT.
EMPLOYEES DO NOT FEEL SECURE IN
THEIR JOBS AND DO NOT FEEL
RESPECTED BY THE LEGISLATURE
DAY.
THAT WAS THE OVERALL QUESTION
55% OF EMPLOYEES BELIEVE
INDIVIDUALS IN POSITIONS OF
POWER SUPPORT AND HARASSMENT
FREE WORK ENVIRONMENT. 38% DO
NOT BELIEVE VICTIMS OR REPORTERS
OF HARASSMENT ARE FREE FROM
RETALIATION. 33% DO NOT BELIEVE
APPROPRIATE ACTUAL BE TAKEN
AFTER A COMPLAINT IS MADE.
WHAT WAS STRIKING ABOUT THE
STATISTICS ONLY LOOKED AT THE
OVERALL REPORT IS?
I DON'T REMEMBER THE EXACT
PERCENTAGE BUT IT WAS A
RELATIVELY HIGH.
PERCENT THAT SAID THEY
UNDERSTOOD OUR POLICY.
SO UNDERSTANDING THE POLICY AND
YET HAVING FEELINGS THAT A
COMPLAINT MORE BE MADE
APPROPRIATE ACTIONS WILL BE
TAKEN.
AND EMPLOYEES WILL BE FREE FROM
RETALIATION REALLY HELPED US
KIND OF LASER FOCUSING IN ON
WHAT OUR CORE.
PROBLEM IS IN TERMS OF OUR
CULTURE AND EMPLOYEES FEELING
HURT AND HAVE IN THE PAST --
TOWARDS HAVING WORKPLACE
CHALLENGES RESOLVE IN A HEALTHY
APPROPRIATE WAY.
NEXT LIVE. TWO OF THOSE WHO WHO
INDICATE THEY HAVE EXPERIENCE
OUR WITNESS HARASSMENT HEY
FEMALES REPORTED HIGHER
INCIDENTS OF HARASSMENT THAN
MEN.
BE THE PERCENTAGE OF SUPERVISORS
REPORT HARASSMENT IS HIGHER THAN
THAT OF NON SUPERVISORS HOWEVER
THE NUMBER OF NON SUPERVISORS
REPORTING HARASSMENT IS GREATER
THAN THAT OF SUPERVISORS SEE.
THE MOST PREVALENT IN THE CASE
OF HARASSMENT RESULTED FROM
LOBBYISTS MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
CAPITAL EMPLOYEES REPORTED
HIGHER INCIDENCE OF THAN THOSE
LOCATED IN THE DISTRICT.
YOU KNOW SEE WAS --
PAINFUL.
CLEAR INFORMATION FOR US ALL TO
RECEIVE I THINK --
AS A RESULT OF SOME OF THE CASES
INVOLVING ELECTED OFFICIALS THAT
LET US DOWN THIS PATH TO REVAMP
IN DEVELOPING THESE NEW SYSTEMS
I THINK OUR ASSUMPTIONS WORD
THAT THE OUTCOME OF THAT
QUESTION WOULD BE DIFFERENT.
AND SO NOW THAT WE'RE CLEAR THAT
--
WE HAVE NOT ONLY TO DEAL WITH
DEVELOPING AN INTERNAL PROCESS
THAT GOVERNS US AS LEGISLATORS
AND STAFF THE STAFF.
BUT ALSO HOW WE MANAGE --
STAFF EXPERIENCES WITH THE
EXTERNAL COMMUNITY THE GENERAL
PUBLIC --
ALSO THOSE WHO ENGAGE AS KEY
STAKEHOLDERS IN OUR WORKPLACE ON
A REGULAR BASIS [inaudible]
NEXT SLIDE.
AND SO THE COMPANY WAS ABLE TO
PROVIDE US WITH A BASED ON THEIR
EXPERTISE IN DOING CLIMATE
SURVEYS.
ARE ENGAGING WITH ORGANIZATIONS
WHO ARE COMMITTED TO IMPROVING
AND CHANGING THEIR WORKPLACE
CULTURE THESE ARE SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THEY
AFFORDED US NUMBER.
ONE POLICIES AND PROCEDURES
ASSESSMENT.
AND AND THE FOCUS IS REVIEW
RESET EVALUATE AND ENFORCED
REVIEW MEANS TO ASSESS POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES AND THEIR LOVE
AND THEIR RELEVANCE TO THE
CURRENT CLIMATE.
ARE THE OUT OF SYNC WITH THE
CULTURE ARE THEY CLEARLY DEFINED
WE HEARD WITNESS AFTER WITNESS
TALK ABOUT.
KIND OF THE DID RESEARCH BASED
EXPERIENCE BASE NEW APPROACH TO
TRAINING AND THAT IS NOT A ONE
SHOT DEAL EVERY TWO YEARS BUT AS
WE KNOW IN TERMS OF OUR OWN
LIVES IN TERMS OF BEAT TRUE
BEHAVIOR CHANGE.
IT REQUIRES A DIFFERENT KIND OF
TRAINING SO WE SPENT A LOT OF
TIME TALKING ABOUT BYSTANDER
TRAINING MORE FREQUENT TRAINING
TRAINING THAT IS DESIGNED WITH
THE LEGISLATURE IN MIND AND SO
IT'S NOT A GENERIC --
AT JANE AND JOE ARE HAVING A
CONVERSATION AT THE WATERCOOLER
BUT REAL EXPERIENCES --
IF YOU ARE A LEAD J..
OR IF YOU ARE A FIELD DEPTH IN A
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC A
CONSTITUENT COMES IN THE OFFICE
AND DOES INAPPROPRIATE THINGS GO
OUT HOW DO YOU MANAGE THOSE.
SO WE'RE CLEAR THAT WE PROBABLY
NEED TO REVIEW OUR POLICIES AND
OUR PRACTICES AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEY REFLECT.
CURRENT BEST PRACTICE IN THE
FIELD OF WORKPLACE HARASSMENT.
RESET EDUCATE EMPLOYEES ON
APPROPRIATE AVENUES TO LOCK
COMPLAINTS BE TRANSPARENT ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENS ONCE THE COMPLAINT
IS MADE.
I THINK THE RESET IS REALLY WHAT
WE'RE FOCUSED ON TODAY IN TERMS
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE TO BRINGING
FORWARD TO JOINT RULES COMMITTEE
A FRAMEWORK FOR A NEW SYSTEM.
EVALUATE FREAK WILL EVALUATE THE
USAGE UNDERSTANDING THIS
EXECUTION OF THE POLICY
PROCEDURE ASSESS.
AND LAST IN FORCE BALANCE
CONFIDENT YET CONFIDENTIALITY
PROCESS WITH TRANSPARENCY IN
INVESTIGATION AND FOLLOW UP.
WITH THE PERSON MAKING THE
REPORT.
REALLY ALL OF THESE BUT TO BE
THOSE LAST TWO ARE INCLUDED IN
THE FRAMEWORK THAT WE'RE PUTTING
FORWARD AS THE CHAIRWOMAN SAID
THIS IS A FRAMEWORK.
ON THIS IS IN A POLICY THAT WILL
REMAIN STATIC ON IS A POLICY
THAT WE KNOW --
AS WE'RE DEVELOPING A FRAMEWORK
THE OF SILLY RULES COMMITTEES --
AND THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE
WILL CONTINUE TO PUT MEAT ON
THOSE BONES AND WILL GO FORWARD
IN DEVELOPING AND STRENGTHENING.
OUR CORPORATE CULTURE AS AN
ORGANIZATION TO BETTER MEET THE
NEEDS OF ALL EMPLOYEES.
I'VE GOT ONE MORE SLIDE I
BELIEVE ADDITIONAL
RECOMMENDATIONS.
LEVERAGING COWORKER ENGAGEMENT
YOU REMEMBER THE SLIDE THAT SAID
OVER 70% OF EMPLOYEES --
ON FELT THAT THEY WERE ENGAGED
WITH THEIR CO WORKERS TO EDUCATE
ALL STAKEHOLDERS AND HOW TO
CREATE A FAIR INCLUSIVE CLIMATE.
UNDERSTAND MORE EMPLOYEES REPORT
WITH THE SENIOR RASPUTIN
EMPLOYEES REPORTED EXPERIENCING
HARASSMENT.
EDUCATE TRAIN EMPLOYEES AND HOT
ANONYMOUS ANONYMOUSLY REPORT
INCIDENTS THE OF WITNESS AND
ENCOURAGE EMPLOYEES TO MAKE
REPORTS.
THE LAST SECTION IS ON
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
TRANSPARENCY MODEL AND EVALUATE
TO BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT THE STEPS
INVOLVED IN THE PROPHECIES
INCLUDING WHO WILL BE COUNTY
COMPLAINTS IN ORDER TO MITIGATE
FEAR OF RETALIATION. TO HOLD
LEADERS ACCOUNTABLE FOR
FOLLOWING APPROPRIATE PROCEDURES
AND CREATE A FAIR AND INCLUSIVE
CLIMATE AND TO MAKE THAT A
PRIORITY.
AND LASTLY AGAINST EVALUATE WE
WILL REASSESS THESE METRIC FOR
THE FOLLOW UP SURVEY TO GAUGE
PROGRESS.
ON THE INDUSTRY STANDARD --
IS TO HAVE A BASELINE WHICH THIS
CLIMATE SURVEY ENDS AND TO THEN
CONDUCT ADDITIONAL SURVEYS USING
THE SAME QUESTION SO YOU HAVE
APPLES TO APPLES COMPARISON.
IN MONTHS OR YEARS TO FOLLOW
WE'RE CLEAR BASED ON THE FACT
THAT WE CAN BE A BUREAUCRATIC.
ORGANIZATION THAT SOMETIME IT
TAKES TIME TO PUT CHANGE IN
MOTION AND SO --
WE'RE CLEAR THAT I THINK WE'VE
AGREED TO PERHAPS SIX MONTHS.
AFTER THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
FRAMEWORK THAT YOU'RE ABOUT TO
HEAR IS IN PLACE THAT WILL GO
BACK AND HAVE ANOTHER CLIMATE
SURVEY SOUL EMPLOYEES HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE FEEL AND
EXPERIENCE A SHIFT IN OUR
CULTURE.
AND THEREBY --
GREATEST ACCORDINGLY.
ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE OF ME
BEFORE WE MOVE ON WITH THE REST
OF THE PRESENTATION.
AGAIN THIS IS A VERY HIGH LEVEL
SUMMARY --
AND THEY'RE ADDITIONAL SLIDES
AVAILABLE ON THAT AGREEMENT MADE
AVAILABLE TO YOU CHIEF OF STAFF
THAT YOU CAN ACCESS --
FOR MORE.
DETAILS ON THE DATA.
THE CUTEST MODEL SURE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SHARES --
THE ONCE LIKE YOU HAD ABOUT THE
NUMBER OF THE LOBBYISTS AND THE
OF OTHER INDIVIDUALS.
YEAH I'M I'M JUST CURIOUS.
IF IF IT DOES A LOBBYIST AFTER
REGISTER. TO COME INTO THIS
BUILDING IS OUR A REQUIREMENT.
HAVING SPENT SOME TIME IN A
PREVIOUS LIFE AS A REGISTERED
LOBBYIST TO TO YOU DO HAVE TO
REGISTER WITH THE SECRETARY OF
STATE.
TO BE CONSIDERED A LOBBYIST TO
ENTER THE BUILDING NIGHT I THINK
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF PEOPLE OUT
INTO THE BUILDINGS I DON'T THINK
THAT'S A PART OF THE REQUIREMENT
TO REGISTER.
BUT YOU DO HAVE TO REGISTER AND
THE PRIDE THAT REGISTRATION
INCLUDES YOU KNOWDOCUMENT YOU
LEFT FILE ON TERMS OF GIFTS YOU
KNOW ALL THAT PROCESS BUT YOU
HAVE. TO SIT THROUGH THE
REGISTERED LOBBYISTS THAT IS A
TERM THAT YES YOU DO REGISTER
SO.
COULD THIS POLICY.
OUR LEASE WE CAN LOOK AT THE
POLICY IF IF YOU HAVE
[inaudible]
BEEN.
SO THAT IF SOMEONE HAS REPORTED
THAT YOU HAVE [inaudible]
USED THEM.
THEN COULD THAT BE A FACTOR IN
WHETHER OR NOT WE REGISTER.
SO THAT THE ACTUAL QUESTION THAT
WAS POSED ON THE SURVEY IT WAS
ONE QUESTION AS I RECALL
REGISTERED LOBBYISTS MEMBER THE
PUBLIC AND SO I THINK THAT WE
SHOULD BE CLEAR.
THAT IT'S A BROAD CATEGORY NOT
JUST REGISTERED LOBBYISTS BUT
THE GENERAL PUBLIC YOU KNOW
DISTRICT OFFICE STAFFS --
ON PARTICIPATED NAM IN THE
SURVEY AS WELL AND SO WE DON'T
KNOW -- OF
ALL THE CASES WHICH FALL UNDER
THE REGISTERED LOBBYISTS
CATEGORY VERSES MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC --
YOU'LL HEAR --
AS THE CHAIR WOMAN WALKS US
THROUGH ALL THE FRAMEWORK THAT
WE'RE PROPOSING ON AN
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF THAT DATA
POINT WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO GO
BACK AND DO SOME ADDITIONAL WORK
TO FIGURE OUT LEGALLY WHAT WE
CAN.
DO PALM BUT I THINK MOST
IMPORTANTLY THE CLIMATE SURVEY
SURFACED FACT AND IT'S NOW ON
EVERYBODY'S RADAR SCREEN AND IT
WILL CLEARLY BE A PART.
OF OF OUR NEW REFORM PROCESS.
CAN DO LEGALLY WE HAVEN'T IRONED
OUT YET BUT I THINK YOUR
QUESTION IS SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD ADD TO OUR PARKING LOT AS
A POTENTIAL SOLUTION.
BUT WE DON'T HAVE THAT SPECIFIC
ANSWER FOR YOU TODAY.
SENATE MITCHELL THANK YOU BOTH
FOR TO GREAT JOB.
IF I MAY JUMP IN ON THAT I THINK
THAT PUTS A SPOTLIGHT ON APPOINT
THE CHAIR FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
HAS STRESSED.
THAT WE HAVE RECOMMENDATIONS
BROUGHT TO US TODAY.
AND REFLECT OUTSTANDING EFFORT
BY THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
BUT I DO THINK OVER THE COURSE
OF TIME AS WE AS WE IMPLEMENT
THAT.
THEY WILL BE SEVEN TWO
REFINEMENT.
THAT -- I I
JUST DON'T TICKETS WERE BEING
HONEST WITH OURSELVES IF WE ACT
TODAY'S IF WE COMPREHENSIVELY
UNDERSTAND WHAT WILL UNFOLD.
THIS BY THE WAY TRACKS WITH WHAT
HAPPENED IN LA COUNTY WHERE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS CAME FROM.
THERE POLICY WENT TO AT LEAST
THREE ITERATIONS OVER TIME.
AND IT ALSO IS IN ACCORD WITH
OUR CURRENT HOUSE RULE ON OUR
HOUSE.
SUBCOMMITTEE ON HARASSMENT.
WHICH CONTEMPLATES THAT WE HAVE
A POLICY BUT WILL BE SEPARATE
REVISIONIST SUBSEQUENT EVENTS
REQUIRE.
SO I JUST THINK YOUR POINT IS A
GOOD.
ONE BUT EXACTLY HOW IT APPLIES
IN THE GIVEN FACT PATTERNS
SINCE.
MANY PEOPLE ENTER THE BUILDING
EXERCISING THEIR FIRST MATTER
RIGHT TO SPEECH.
SOME HAVE A FORMAL BUSINESS ROLE
HERE IS RICHARD LOBBYIST.
BUT ULTIMATELY WE ARE CONCERNED
WITH IN GENERAL ENVIRONMENT THAT
IS FAIR AND SAFE AND PEOPLE KNOW
WHAT'S.
ALLOWABLE I JUST DO THINK THERE
WILL BE A LEARNING CURVE A TO
CONTINUE THE WORK.
THAT WHAT A HEAVY LIFT OF
LEARNING OTHER SUBCOMMITTEES
ENGAGED IN.
SO IT'S AN ONGOING WORK A TO BE
SURE.
A LOT WITH THAT [inaudible]
MS FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU --
HAD THANK YOU --
SENATOR MITCHELL I'M NOT GOING
TO BE REDUNDANT TRY NOT TO BE
REDONE WITH ANYTHING THAT SHE
PRESENTED TO YOU --
I'M GOING TO OUTLINE --
THE FRAMEWORK FOR THIS POLICY OF
COURSE YOU ALL HAVE WRITTEN
DOCUMENTS THAT THAT GIVE A LOT
MORE DETAIL SO THIS WILL BE A
MORE HIGH LEVEL DISCUSSION --
FIRST OF ALL EVERY CHANGE THAT
WE'RE RECOMMENDING TO EVERY
ASPECT OF THIS POLICY IS WITH
WITH THE GOAL OF CULTURE CHANGE
IN THE INSTITUTION.
AS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT --
WRITTEN POLICY IS MEANINGLESS
WITHOUT THAT REAL CULTURAL BRIAN
AND CULTURE CHANGE AND SO THAT'S
WHAT ALL OF THIS POLICY IS
REALLY INTENDING TO DO.
AT THE END OF THE DAY --
AND THAT CULTURE CHANGE IS --
ONE TWO CREATE AN ENVIRONMENT OF
RESPECTABILITY AND DIVERSITY
WITHIN THE LEGISLATURE --
THE BEGINNING OF ALL OF THAT OF
COURSE IS A MUCH MORE
COMPREHENSIVE KIND OF TRAINING
PROGRAM AS THE SENATOR
MENTIONED.
TRAINING THAT'S MORE RELEVANT TO
OUR PARTICULAR WORKPLACE WITH
MORE EXPLANATIONS ABOUT SOME OF
THE GRAY AREAS THAT THAT WE HAVE
BETWEEN OUR WORK QUOTE UNQUOTE
WORK ENVIRONMENT HERE IN THE
BUILDING BUT THEN.
THE OFTEN BEING OUT IN THE
FIELD.
STILL ENCOUNTERING MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN YOUR OFFICIAL
CAPACITY AND STAFFERS AND MAKING
SURE THAT PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THAT
THAT'S STILL AN EXTENSION OF
YOUR WORKPLACE IN OUR POLICY
STILL APPLY.
IN BRINGING IN --
TRAINING THAT HAS MORE --
QUANTITATIVE DATA OF EFFICACY A
RETRAINING LIKE BYSTANDER
TRAINING AN IMPLICIT BIAS
TRAINING AND AND I INTERACTIVE
BEST PRACTICES THAT ARE OUT
THERE TO HAVE A MUCH MORE
ENGAGING AND ONGOING.
TRAINING FOR UP FOR EVERYBODY
WHO WORKS IN THIS BUILDING.
OUR CODE IS ASPIRATIONAL IT'S
MUCH BROADER THAN WHAT WE'VE HAD
BEFORE IN TERMS OF THE TYPE OF
BEHAVIOR THAT IT COVERS AND
THAT'S GOING TO BE A SEA CHANGE
FOR THE LEGISLATURE.
WE ARE NO LONGER GOING TO WAIT
FOR SOMETHING TO RISE TO THE
LEVEL OF LEGALLY ACTIONABLE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT TO TAKE
ACTION.
AND THE REASON FOR THAT IS
BECAUSE ONE ELEMENT OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT IS PERVASIVENESS SO
IF WE CAN COME IN EARLY.
THE VERY FIRST TIME AN INCIDENT
OCCURS ONE JOKE ONE
INAPPROPRIATE PHYSICAL CONDUCT.
BOB ONE INAPPROPRIATE IMAGE
BEING SHARED ON A COMPUTER.
WE CAN THEN OFFER TRAINING AND
COUNSELING AND CORRECT THAT
BEHAVIOR BEFORE WE DO HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE A STAFFER FEELS
THAT THEY'VE BEEN IN UP HOSTILE
WORKPLACE. FOR MONTHS ON END
FEELS THAT THEY HAVE O COME FOR
WITH A VERY SERIOUS ALLEGATION
TO DO THAT IT MEANS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE ASKING OUR STAFF AND
EACH OTHER. TO REPORT ON THOSE
SORTS OF INCIDENCES --
AND IN A MUCH EARLIER IN MUCH
DIFFERENT WAY.
AND AGAIN THE GOAL IS TOWARDS
CORRECT CREEK CORRECTIVE
BEHAVIOR NOT PUNITIVE ACTION SO
THAT WE CAN GIVE THAT EMPLOYEE
OR EACH OTHER THE CHANCE TO
COURSE CORRECT --
WE THINK THAT THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT WE'VE SEEN AND FOR
INSTANCE WAS REFERENCE LA COUNTY
WHICH HAS A SIMILAR KIND OF CODE
OF CONDUCT.
THAT THAT BEGINS THEN THE DISK
BUT THAT THE ACTUAL CULTURAL
CHANGE IN THE WORKPLACE BECAUSE
THEN YOU HAVE EMPLOYEES
THINKING.
IS THIS ACTION GOING TO BE
SOMETHING THAT'S REPORTABLE
RATHER THAN SAYING WELL I CAN
HAVE X. AMOUNT OF INAPPROPRIATE
CONDUCT BEFORE IT IT CROSSES THE
LINE YOU WANT TO GET IN EARLY
AND STOP THAT BEHAVIOR --
THAT CODE OF CONDUCT FOR THIS
PART OF THIS PROCESS IS BASED ON
PROTECTED CLASS.
SO AGE GENDER DISABILITY SEXUAL
ORIENTATION RACE.
BASED ON THAT PROTECTED CLASS
WILL MOVE IT INTO THE REALM OF
THIS POLICY RATHER THAN A
TYPICAL HUMAN RESOURCES TRACK
WHICH OTHER TYPES OF WORKPLACE
INCIDENTS WILL STILL CONTINUE TO
BE REFERRED.
AND AGAIN ALL OF OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS REINFORCED
CHANGE SO HOW ARE WE GOING TO DO
THAT.
OF THE BEGINNING OF THAT IS TO
ESTABLISH AN INDEPENDENT UNIT.
WHICH WILL BE HOUSE UNDER
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL BUT WILL BE
INDEPENDENT AND SIGH LOAD SO
THAT I CAN WORK WITHOUT.
WITHOUT SORT OF HAVING THE
OVERSIGHT OF THIS OF LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL.
WHO BOMBED AND THE THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THAT BRINGS SO?
THAT INDEPENDENT LEGISLATIVE
WORKPLACE.
YOU TO CUT OUR CONDUCT UNIT.
WILL BE BI CAMERAL WHICH IS
AGAIN A SEA CHANGE FOR HOW WE
OPERATE.
IT WILL BE INDEPENDENT OF OTHER.
IT SEE IT IS SEEN AS BEING
UNBIASED AND FAIR TO EVERYBODY
WHO.
GOES WELL I'M IN FRONT OF IT.
IT WILL HAVE TRAIN SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS. TO WORK ON THESE
ISSUES IT WILL BE IN PLACE TO
ADVISE SUPERVISORS AND STOP ON
WORKPLACE CONDUCT.
ITS DUTIES WILL BE TO TAKE
REPORTS TO DO AND IN THE INITIAL
INVESTIGATION AND ASSESSMENT.
AND ALSO INVESTIGATIONS AND WHAT
WE HEARD FROM THE EXPERTS WHO
TALKED TO US ABOUT
INVESTIGATIONS WASTE TYPES OF
INVESTIGATIONS IS YOU MUST AS AN
EMPLOYER BE ABLE TO GET TO THE
PLACE FOR YOUR EMPLOYEES BELIEVE
THAT YOU CAN CONDUCT FAIR
INVESTIGATIONS.
WHICH MEANS DOING THOSE IN HOUSE
HOWEVER IF THE INVESTIGATORS ARE
BEING ASKED TO DO INVESTIGATIONS
ON THOSE WHO ARE CONSIDERED TO
BE ABOVE THEM ON THE
ORGANIZATIONAL CHART LIKE
MEMBERS.
THAT'S WHERE YOU WOULD PROBABLY
SEND THAT OUT FOR EXTERNAL
INVESTIGATIONS SO THERE'S SORT
OF A CLEAR YOU KNOW DEMARCATION
LINE AS TO WHAT YOU DO
INTERNALLY AND WHAT YOU DO
EXTERNALLY BUT YOU MUST GET TO
THE POINT WHERE YOU CAN DO THE
MAJORITY OF YOUR STAFF YOU KNOW
YOUR YOUR ORDINARY.
INVESTIGATIONS INTERNALLY.
AND THERE WILL BE TIMES WHERE
YOU DON'T NEED TO DO THOSE KINDS
OF INVESTIGATIONS BECAUSE THE
PARTIES WILL ALL AGREE ON WHAT
HAPPENED AND WHAT THE INCIDENT
WAS [inaudible]
AS WELL --
THAT UNIT WILL BE AS AGAIN
INDEPENDENT FROM EITHER HOUSE.
IT WILL BE ABLE TO OFFER
IMMEDIATE ASSESSMENT AND
INTERVENTION SO EVERY INCIDENT
THAT COMES IN WILL BE TRIAGE TO
SEE IF IMMEDIATE ACTION NEEDS TO
BE TAKEN.
OR WHETHER IT'S SOMETHING THAT
WOULD GO OUT FOR INVESTIGATION
AT WHAT LEVEL SO IMMEDIATE
TRIAGE IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
IT WILL ACCEPT ANONYMOUS
COMPLAINTS IT WILL ACCEPT
COMPLAINTS FROM EXTERNAL PEOPLE
SO ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC WHO
WALKS AND WHO HAS AN INCIDENT
WITH ONE OF OUR STAFFERS OR
LEGISLATOR.
WOULD BE ABLE TO GO IN FRONT OF
THAT TO BRING THAT TO THE PANEL.
IT WILL ALSO HAVE SOME SORT OF
INVESTIGATIVE RESPONSIBILITIES
AGAINST MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
BECAUSE WE OWE OUR EMPLOYEES THE
RESPONSIBILITY THAT IF THEY HAVE
HER* MEANT THAT SERIOUS
COMING FROM.
A LOT A LOBBYIST A MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC WE HAVE TO INVESTIGATE
THAT WE HAVE TO PROTECT THAT
EMPLOYEE.
AS SENATOR MITCHELL INDICATED
THERE IS A LIMIT TO WHAT WE CAN
DO WHAT OUR RESPONSE CAN BE BUT
WE STILL HAVE. TO TO INVESTIGATE
THAT INCIDENT AND MAKE A
DETERMINATION AND FIND A WAY TO
PROTECT AN EMPLOYEE IF THERE
REALLY AND THAT KIND OF A
SITUATION SO THAT WILL BE DONE
AND THAT'S PART OF THE POLICY
THAT'S GOING TO HAVE TO BE.
DEVELOPED OVER TIME --
CERTAINLY.
THE INVESTIGATIONS WILL BE
TIMELY EVIDENCE WILL BE
COLLECTED THOSE WHO MAKE THAT --
REPORT WILL BE KEPT --
INFORMED AS TO THE PROGRESS AND
YOU KNOW AS TO YOU KNOW SO THAT
THEY KNOW THAT THE
INVESTIGATIONS BEING DONE AND
TAKEN SERIOUSLY.
AND WILL READ WE WILL RETAIN
WE'VE WHICH WE RECENTLY BROUGHT
AND FOR EMPLOYEE COUNSELING WE
DOES NOT DO INVESTIGATIONS THEY
DO NOT OFFER LEGAL ADVICE BUT
THEY DO OFFER A LOT OF PORT AND
GIVING OF INFORMATION TO
EMPLOYEES SO THAT THEY CAN GO
SOMEWHERE THAT'S OUTSIDE OF THE
REALM.
OF YOU KNOW OUR FORMAL PROCESS
TO GET INFORMATION AND WE'VE OF
COURSE WILL.
BE -- GIVEN
THE FULL POLICIES SO THEY
UNDERSTAND THE POLICY AND CAN
GIVE COUNSELING TO EMPLOYEES
BASED ON OUR POLICY AS WELL AS
THE LAW.
WITHIN THAT INDEPENDENT UNIT WE
WILL BE CREATING AN INDEPENDENT
PANEL OF AN INDEPENDENT.
THOUGHT OUTSIDE PANEL WHICH IS
AGAIN VERY NEW TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND I DON'T KNOW
THAT THIS IS BEING DONE ANY
LEGISLATURE STATE HOUSE AROUND
THE COUNTRY.
THIS PANEL WILL CONSIST OF
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS PEOPLE
WITH DECADES OF EXPERIENCE IN
THIS FIELD THE TYPICAL TYPE OF
PEOPLE THAT WILL BE ON THE PANEL
WILL BE EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS WHO
HAVE WORKED BOTH ON THE EMPLOYEE
SIDE AND ON THE EMPLOYER SIDE.
RETIRED JUDGES WHO HAVE BEEN A
HEARING THESE CASES FOR MANY
YEARS PEOPLE THAT WE ALL WOULD
AGREE.
ARE --
REALLY SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS IN
THIS AREA.
THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE
PANEL WILL BE OVERSIGHT OF THE
INDEPENDENT UNITS ASSESSMENTS.
TO REVIEW THE EVIDENCE COLLECTED
BY INVESTIGATORS TO DETERMINE ON
THE FACTUAL FINDINGS OF IN THE
OF WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
INCIDENTS TO DETERMINE WHETHER
THERE WAS INDEED A VIOLATION OF
OUR POLICIES.
AND IF SO AT WHAT KIND OF WHAT
LEVEL OF VIOLATION. TO BRIEF THE
RELEVANT HOUSE IN THE SUPERVISOR
AND THEN TO MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS
ON THERE ON WHAT THEY BELIEVE
THE APPROPRIATE RESPONSE.
SHOULD BE A TYPE OF DISCIPLINE
TYPES OF TRAINING THOSE KINDS OF
RECOMMENDATIONS BASED ON THEIR
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE.
EACH HOUSE WILL RETAIN THE FINAL
DECISION MAKING AUTHORITY.
IN THOSE CASES THEY WILL
DETERMINE HOW TO RESPOND TO THE
PANELS.
ALMOND THEY WILL --
IT DOCUMENT FINAL DECISIONS ON
THE RESPONSE AND THAT WILL BE
DOCUMENTED.
THE HOUSE WILL ISSUE LETTERS
FROM A A TO THE SUBJECT OF THE
INQUIRY THE SUBJECT BEING THE
PERSON YOU KNOW WHO MAY HAVE
MADE THE INAPPROPRIATE.
THEY'VE DONE THE INAPPROPRIATE
CONDUCT THEY WILL RECEIVE A
SUMMARY OF THE PANEL FINDINGS
AND THE TERMS THE TYPES OF
RESPONSES THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
ANTICIPATE.
AND THEN IN TERMS OF
CONFIDENTIALITY I'M THAT WE WILL
MAINTAIN CONFIDENTIALITY TO THE
EXTENT POSSIBLE BECAUSE WE HAVE
LEARNED FROM EVERY SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERT THAT'S BECAUSE
THAT HAS COME IN BUT THAT
ENCOURAGING ENCOURAGES
REPORTING.
PEOPLE WHO REPORT THESE --
ARE REPORTING THEM TO US BECAUSE
THEY EXPECT BECAUSE THEY WANT A
RESPONSE BUT THEY ALSO WANT
CONFIDENTIALITY AS MUCH AS WE
CAN GIVE IT --
AND THE PERSON WHO IS THE
SUBJECT OF CONFIDENTIALITY
BECAUSE THESE ARE INTERNAL
WORKPLACE INCIDENTS.
IF WE WANT. TO ASK OUR EMPLOYEES
AND EACH OTHER TO FOR THE FIRST
TIME REPORT.
A VERY BROAD RANGE OF CONDUCT
THINGS THAT FALL WAY BELOW ANY
COULD OF LEGAL DEFINITION OF
HARASSMENT OR DISCRIMINATION WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
REPORTS ARE CONFIDENTIAL.
IF OUR INTENTION IS REALLY TO
GET AN EARLY TO OFFER TRAINING
AND COUNSELING THAT SHOULD BE
DONE CONFIDENTIALITY BECAUSE IF
NOT IT'S GOING TO BE HARDER. TO
GET PEOPLE TO REPORT THOSE KINDS
OF VIOLATIONS SO IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT TO THE EXTENT THAT WE CAN
FOR THOSE.
EARLY TYPES OF ARMOR --
OF REPORTS THAT WE MAINTAIN
CONFIDENTIALITY AS MUCH AS WE
CAN TO ENCOURAGE MORE REPORTING
HOWEVER WE'RE GOING TO MAINTAIN
THE CURRENT POLICY ON DISCLOSURE
WHEN IT COMES TO MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND SENIOR STAFF
[inaudible]
THAT WHEN THERE'S A
DETERMINATION THAT THERE HAS
BEEN AN A SUSTAINED ALLEGATION
OF SERIOUS SEXUAL HARASSMENT
THAT WILL CONTINUE TO BE
RELEASED AS IT IS NOW UNDER OUR
POLICY -- WE
WILL OF COURSE REDACT AS MUCH AS
WE CAN AND THE IDENTITIES OF THE
VICTIMS AND WITNESSES --
BUT WE ALSO NEED TO BE CAREFUL
TO MAINTAIN THAT PRIVACY AND
CONFIDENTIALITY WITH THE
PUBLIC'S LEGAL AT OUR RIGHT TO
KNOW AND THEIR EXPECTATIONS WHEN
IT COMES TO MEMBERS AND SENIOR
STAFF.
I'M WITH THAT I WILL TAKE
QUESTIONS AND THAT'S THE GENERAL
FRAMEWORK OF THE POLICY IT IS A
RADICAL DEPARTURE FROM WHAT'S
BEEN DONE IN THE PAST.
HAVING AN OUTSIDE GROUP MAKING
THE DETERMINATIONS OF WHETHER
THERE WAS A VIOLATION OF POLICY
IS PRETTY RADICAL.
HAVING ALSO THEY'RE MAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT HOPEFULLY
WILL BE FOLLOWED IN MOST
INSTANCES IS ALSO A BIG CHANGE
BUT I THINK THAT THAT'S WHAT WE
NEED TO GIVE THE PERCEPTION OF
FAIRNESS TO EVERYBODY. TO HAVE A
POLICY THAT OPERATES THE SAME
WHETHER IT'S A MEMBER OF THE
LEGISLATURE OR A STAFFER THEY
WILL GO DOWN THE EXACT SAME TRAP
WITH THE EXACT.
SAME TYPE OF PROCESS --
A I THINK IT'S A FAIR POLICY AND
HAVING THAT INDEPENDENT UNIT
WITH OUTSIDE INVESTIGATORS WHO
ARE UNDER CONTRACT THE
LEGISLATURE BUT NOT EMPLOYEES OF
THE LEGISLATURE --
WITH EXPECTATIONS WITH WRITTEN
RIGHT WITHIN THEIR CONTRACT OF
THE TYPE OF UNBIASED AND FAIR
DETERMINATIONS THAT WE EXPECT
THEM TO MAKE.
I THINK SHOULD GIVE EVERYBODY
THE CONFIDENCE THAT WE HAVE SET
UP A FRAMEWORK THAT'S INTENDED
TO BE FAIR --
TO EVERYBODY WITH THE RIGHT
BALANCE OF DISCLOSURE AND
CONFIDENTIALITY FOR OUR
EMPLOYEES.
I'M WITHOUT I WILL SEE IF MY
VICE CHAIRS ANYTHING TO ADD
BECAUSE IT'S A LOT OF
INFORMATION IN A CONDENSED
PERIOD OF TIME IN THE MUGGLE
QUESTIONS.
WHAT IT WOULD?
MADAM CHAIR YOU MENTION THAT
IT'S IT'S IT'S A HUGE DEPARTURE
AND SOMETHING NEW IN TERMS OF
THE PANEL I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT AND THAT MEMBERS
UNDERSTOOD THAT IT'S WE'VE
LOOKED AT A EXISTING.
ALL THE LA COUNTY.
THE YEARS THEY'VE BEEN IN
EXISTENCE YES THANK YOU IN TERMS
OF THE PANEL --
PART OF THIS THE IMPANELED
MAKING THE DECISION ABOUT
WHETHER THERE'S BEEN A A
VIOLATION OF OUR POLICY AND THEN
MAKING THE RECOMMEND RECOMMENDED
RESPONSES.
ON LA COUNTY INSTITUTED THIS
MODEL MANY YEARS AGO HAVING TO
DO WITH A CULTURE PROBLEMS THAT
THEY HAD IN THEIR PUBLIC SAFETY
DIVISIONS.
I AND THEN IT WAS SO SUCCESSFUL
IN PUBLIC SAFETY THAT THEY
ROLLED OUT ACROSS THEIR ENTIRE
WORKFORCE WHICH IS A HUNDRED
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES STRONG.
WHAT'S INTERESTING ABOUT LA
COUNTY IS THAT THEY HAVE A VERY
DIVERSE WORKFORCE THEY HAVE.
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENTS THAT MAY
HAVE FIVE PEOPLE ARE PUBLIC
SAFETY DIVISIONS THAT ARE OUT IN
A RURAL PART OF LA COUNTY WITH
JUST A COUPLE OF PEOPLE.
AND THEN THEY HAVE HOSPITALS
THAT MIGHT HAVE TEN PLEASE SO
THEY HAVE FOUND THAT THIS
PROCESS WORKS ALL ACROSS THOSE
DIFFERENT VARIED WORK FORCES AND
WE'VE GOT DISTRICT OFFICES THAT
ARE SMALL OUT ON THE FIELD AND
WE'VE GOT.
YOU KNOW THE BUILDING HERE.
THEY ALSO BECAUSE THEY ALSO HAVE
A VERY BROAD POLICY THAT COVERS
A VERY BROAD RANGE OF
INAPPROPRIATE CONDUCT AND THEY
THEY ACTUALLY ASK ALL OF THEIR
EMPLOYEES WHETHER SUPERVISORS
ARE NOT TO REPORT THOSE.
THEY FIND THAT THEY'RE IN THE
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT'S AN
APPROPRIATE WITH THEIR EMPLOYEES
HAS REALLY INCREASED
DRAMATICALLY OVER THE YEARS AND
IN FACT.
I WENT DOWN TO WATCH THE PANEL
AND I SAW A CASE WERE EMPLOYEES
WHO WERE NOT EVEN YOU KNOW HIGH
LEVEL SUPERVISORS NEW THE
PROCESS SO MUCH THAT ONE
INCIDENT OCCURRED.
THE IMMEDIATELY SAT DOWN EACH
ROAD UP A NEW GUY A SORT OF AN
AFFIDAVIT OF WHAT HAD OCCURRED
SO THAT LATER ON THERE WOULDN'T
BE ANYONE.
RE REMEMBERING WHAT HAPPENED AND
THEY WERE VERY FAMILIAR WITH THE
PROCESS AND THAT'S THE BEGINNING
OF CULTURE CHANGE BECAUSE WHEN
YOUR EMPLOYEES START TO
INTERNALIZE THIS.
AND START THINKING TO THEMSELVES
WITHOUT A VIOLATION OF CONDUCT
MAYBE I SHOULD INTERVENE MAYBE I
NEED TO TALK TO THAT PERSON
MAYBE WE SHOULD ALL SIT DOWN AND
WRITE.
RIGHT THIS INCIDENT UP AND SEE
IF IT'S A VIOLATION THAT'S WHEN
YOU REALLY BIG BEGIN TO HAVE
THAT CULTURE CHANGE SO THEY'VE
HAD A LOT OF SUCCESS --
DOING THIS OVER THE PAST I THINK
IT'S FIFTEEN YEARS AND WE WERE
VERY IMPRESSED NO OF COURSE THE
POLICY HAS BEEN TAILORED TO OUR
WORKPLACE BECAUSE WE ARE
DIFFERENT WERE VERY TOP HEAVY.
WITH ELECTED OFFICIALS WERE IS
THEY HAVE FIVE SUPERVISORS IN
JUST A COUPLE OF OTHER ELECTED
IN A HUNDRED THOUSAND EMPLOYEES
SO WE HAD TO CHANGE IT A BIT.
BUT THAT BASIC TENANT OF AN
INDEPENDENT PANEL BIT OF OF
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS. TO
INVESTIGATE AND ADJUDICATED WE
THOUGHT WAS VERY IMPRESSIVE AND
FIT VERY WELL WITH WITH OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND THE ONLY THING I
WOULD ADD IS THAT THE THE POLICY
APPLIES TO THE ELECTED BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS TO THAT'SWHAT WE
THOUGHT.
ONLY LOOKED AT MODELS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY THAT IT --
WAS GERMANE TO OUR EXPERIENCE
WITH A PLACID EMPLOYEES.
AS WELL AS THE ELECTED OFFICIALS
[inaudible]
CENTER MONEY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I ALSO
JUST WANT TO APPLAUD THE CO
CHAIRS IN THE COMMITTEE FOR
THIS.
REALLY IMPORTANT HISTORIC WORK
IN.
NOT STARTING FROM SCRATCH BUT
LEARNING FROM OTHER
JURISDICTIONS PARTICULARLY LOS
ANGELES [inaudible]
IN.
I'M LOOKING AT PAGE FIVE ON THE
RECOMMENDED POLICY.
AND I THINK ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES WITHOUT GETTING TOO
MUCH IN THE WE'D SPENT.
OF MOVING FORWARD OF EDUCATING
STAFF THERE IS KIND OF A GRAY
AREA OF THE ABILITY [inaudible]
TO ASSURE.
AND ACCUSER OR WITNESS OF
CONFIDENTIALITY --
AND IN THE LANGUAGE REFLECTS
THAT -- YOU
DO HAVE A LEGISLATURE CANNOT
GUARANTEE CONFIDENTIALITY BUT IT
CAN MAKE AN EFFORT TO MAINTAIN
THE CONFIDENTIALITY FOR THE LAW
ALLOWS [inaudible]
SO.
IN THE TRAINING I THINK WE NEED
TO BACK SOME OF THIS RECOMMENDED
POLICY INTO TRAINING.
REALIZING THERE STILL MAY BE A
GRAY AREA THAT COULD STILL
SERVICE A RESTRAINT.
FOR EITHER A VICTIM OR A WITNESS
TO FEEL FULLY COMFORTABLE COMING
FORWARD.
AND I THINK THERE IS SOME
DISTINCTION BETWEEN.
WHAT DOES GET RELEASED
ULTIMATELY TO THE PUBLIC IF IT'S
A HIGH RANKING STAFF MEMBER OR
LEGISLATOR --
YOU CAN TRY TO ASSURE THE
CONFIDENTIALITY THE COMPLAINANT.
THAT IF IF THE ACCUSED NAME
BECOMES PUBLIC AS A MATTER OF
TRANSPARENCY IN [inaudible]
PUBLIC POLICY [inaudible]
THAT ME [inaudible]
UNINTENTIONALLY.
REVEAL THE IDENTITY OF AT LEAST
A GROUP OF EMPLOYEES SO I DON'T
HAVE A SOLUTION FOR THAT I THINK
YOU FLAGGED.
THE CHALLENGE ON THE ONE HAND WE
WANNA.
HAVE THAT TRANSPARENCY FOR
CERTAIN LEVEL OF COMPLAINTS
THAT.
IT DOES GET SHARED WITH A
COMMITMENT TO PROTECT
CONFIDENTIALITY.
ON BUT IT'S A LITTLE TRICKY AND
I THINK WHO IN THE TRAINING
PEOPLE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE --
EVEN THOUGH WE DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO PROTECT CONFIDENTIALITY
FOR IT SOUGHT.
CIRCUMSTANCES AND OR THE LAW
MAIN --
ALLOW US TO MAKE GOOD SO FOR
SUPERVISORS FOR PEOPLE
INTRODUCING THE POLICY IN IN
TRAINING.
I THINK WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO BE
CANDID WITH TRANSPARENT WHERE
THERE ARE GRAY AREAS.
BUT COULDN'T AGREE WITH YOU MORE
SIR I THINK OUR SUBTITLE
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS CAN ATTEST
WE SPENT A GREAT DEAL OF TIME.
TALKING ABOUT REALLY TERMINOLOGY
AND AND HOW WE HAVE TO HAVE TO
CREATE A SCENARIO WHERE WE HAVE
COMMON UNDERSTANDING OF WORDS
AND SO WE TALKED ABOUT.
ANONYMOUS REPORTING AND
CONFIDENTIALITY IN TRANSPARENCY.
AND HOW --
WE FEEL A HIGHLY.
GET THE NEW POLICY IN PLACE.
AND AND OUR NUMBERS AROUND
CONCERN AROUND RETALIATION
DECREASE PEOPLE WILL HAVE A
WORKING KNOWLEDGE OF THE POLICY
AND WILL BE WILLING TO KIND OF
WORK WITHIN ITS CONFINES AS
DEFINED BY LAW.
SO WE AGREE WITH YOU WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT'S A VERY
DELICATE AND ARE AND A PART OF
THE CULTURE HE IF YOU KEEP
HEARING THAT'S USED THE TERM.
IS ABOUT MAKING SURE PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND ALL OF THOSE THINGS
NEW WANTS AND STRAIGHT FORWARD
THANK YOU NEW DIGS THERE IS A
NEXUS ALSO WITH.
FEAR OF RETALIATION AND IF WE
CAN BUILD CONFIDENCE AND THERE'S
NO QUARTER FOR RETALIATION.
IT MA'AM GOLDEN PEOPLE TO FEEL
MORE CONFIDENT.
EVEN IF IT SOME POINT IN THE
PROCESS.
THERE IDENTITY MY DID BECOME
KNOWN ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALSO JUST
--
AT THAT TIME.
THE INTENTION RITE NOW IS THAT
IF THERE'S A A COMPLAINT ABOUT
RETALIATION BASED ON ONE OF
THESE CLAIMS THAT THE SAME
PANEL.
WILL BE HEARING THAT AND THESE
ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE FAMILIAR
WITH THE CASE AND CAN.
CAN HEAR ABOUT AND WE TAKE THAT
VERY VERY SERIOUSLY AND I ALSO
WANT TO ADD A BECAUSE IT DONE
THE PRESSES TALKED ABOUT THIS A
BIT IN TERMS OF WHAT WE'RE GONNA
DISCLOSE IN WHAT WE'RE NOT TO
THE PUBLIC.
THAT LA COUNTY THEY DISCLOSE
NOTHING [inaudible]
NOTHING THEY DON'T DISCLOSE
COMPLAINTS AGAINST THEIR BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS IF THAT HAPPENS
THEY DON'T DISCLOSE ANY OF A
THEY CONSIDER AT ALL TO BE
INTERNAL HR.
MATTERS BECAUSE THEY WANT PEOPLE
TO FEEL FREE TO COME FORWARD AND
MAKE THESE I'M A REPORT THESE
INCIDENCES.
I NEVER A CLEAR THAT THAT'S THE
REASON THAT THEY KEEP THIS
INTERNAL WE ARE GOING BEYOND
THAT WE FEEL THAT THE PUBLIC A
WE ARE BELIEF HERE IS THAT THE
PUBLIC HAS A RIGHT TO KNOW ABOUT
I'M INCIDENCES THAT ARE SERIOUS.
WITH LEGISLATORS AND SENIOR
STAFF -- BUT
AGAIN IT IS A BALANCE BECAUSE WE
DON'T WANNA HAVE A CHILLING
EFFECT ON PEOPLE I'M REPORTING
INCIDENTS.
ASSUME REPUBLICAN LEADER TALLY
IN A JUMPING ON THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBER PARTICIPANTS
LEASE TAUGHT US QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
OUT SO ONE OF THE CONVERSATIONS
WE HAD DURING THE MANY MEETINGS
THAT WE HAD WAS.
ABOUT YOU KNOW EVEN AS US IS
ELECTED'S.
WHERE YOU HAVE AN ALLEGATION AND
IT HITS THE FRONT PAGE OF THE
PAPER DURING ELECTION RIGHT SO
THAT'S NOT FAIR EITHER SO I?
WE WE WRANGLED AROUND AND TALKED
ABOUT THIS AT LEAT.
AND THE ONE THING THAT DUMB.
WITH THIS POLICY IN PLACE
THEY'LL EAT HERE IT IT WILL GIVE
US THE ABILITY IT WILL TAKE
SOMETIME I THINK --
BUT WHEN THERE'S CONFIDENCE IN
THIS PROCESS WORKING WE CAN SAY
HEY ALL OF THE REPORTS GO TO THE
COMMITTEE.
THEY'RE VETTED THEY ARE --
REVIEWED BY PROFESSIONALS AND
THEN WHATEVER THAT OUTCOME IS IS
THE OUTCOME.
AND SO -- IF
THERE'S AN ABILITY FOR SOMEBODY
OR AN OPPORTUNITY FOR SOME
MITCHELL USE THAT POLITICALLY WE
CAN THEN ALL POINT TOWARDS NO
WE'RE NOT ACCEPTING THAT THAT'S
A THAT'S A POLITICAL STATEMENT
FOR NOW.
UNTIL WE GET THE FACTS FROM --
THIS NONPARTISAN --
PROFESSIONAL COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
SARAH.
THANK YOU AGAIN SO COMMITTEE DID
PHENOMENAL WORK OF IS A FORMER
STAFFER --
THIS IS VERY VERY IMPORTANT --
AND MY QUESTION IS IN TERMS OF
THE FOLKS IN OUR DISTRICT
OFFICE.
WHO INTERACT WITH CONCERN SO
YOUR CONSTITUENTS SOMETIMES --
AND HAVING THEM VERY CLEARLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEIR RIGHTS
ARE.
A TO PROTECT THEMSELVES --
FROM SOME COMMUTERS COMMUNITY
MEMBERS ARE CONSTITUENTS AND SO
FORTH THING THAT'S VERY KEY TO
THIS AS WELL IN JUST OVER A
HARASSMENT IN GENERAL.
OTHERS BUT SEVERAL INCIDENTS
WHERE YOU KNOW WE WE STAFFER
TALK TO BE YOU KNOW COURTEOUS
AND OPEN THE DOOR FOR FOLKS AND
SOMETIMES UP JUNE DOESN'T TURN
OUT VERY WELL --
SO THIS IS.
PARAMOUNT TO ENSURING THAT THEY
ALSO KNOW WHAT THEIR RIGHTS ARE
AS EMPLOYEES IN THE CAPITAL IN
THE DISTRICT OFFICE.
THE ONLY THING I WOULD ASK AND
ADD IT TO SOME THOUGHTS ABOUT.
MAKING SURE THAT STAFF
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY'RE
PROTECTIONS ARE AND WHAT WE AS
AN INSTITUTION.
CAN DO TO PROTECT THEM WHETHER
THAT'S THERE THERE SAFETY
THROUGH OUR SERGEANTS ORDER
REPRESENTATION BECAUSE THERE'S
ALWAYS BEEN KIND OF THAT.
GRAY AREA WHILE YOU KNOW WE HEAR
MEMBERS ARE PROTECTED BUT STAFF
ARE AND SO FORTH AND SO THAT
KINDA LEADS TO SOME.
KIND OF ANIMOSITY AS WELL FOR
PEOPLE WANTING TO BE ABLE --
TO RABAA FRONT AND OPEN ABOUT
SOMETHING HAPPENING BECAUSE YOU
KNOW OUR STAFF MAY NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO LEGAL REPRESENTATION
TO THAT ALSO.
AFFECTS PEOPLE WANTING TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROCESS JUST
SOME THOUGHTS ON ON THAT.
YEAH CLOSER ON THE REALLY
IMPORTANT AFTER UNDERSTAND THAT
I THINK THAT FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
SO EXPERIENCES ARE NOT --
THEY DON'T ALWAYS UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE IN A
SITUATION WHERE YOU DON'T FEEL
SAFE OR WERE YOU FEEL THAT
YOU'RE REALLY VISION EMOTIONALLY
ABUSED OR HARASSED.
YOU REALLY SHOULDN'T BE THERE AS
A STAFFER AND YOU KNOW THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT YOU SHOULD BE
TELLING A SUPERVISOR ABOUT.
SO THAT WE CAN PROTECT YOU I'M I
DO WANT AND SO THAT SHOULD BE
PART OF OUR TRAINING ARE
ABSOLUTELY.
AND I I NEVER RECEIVED TRAINING
LIKE THAT SO I DON'T KNOW IF IF
STAFF IS REALLY GIVEN THAT KIND
OF TRAINING SO I THINK
FORMALIZING THAT'S IMPORTANT.
I DO WANNA I'M SAY ONCE AGAIN
THAT THIS PARTICULAR THIS POLICY
THIS CONDUCT POLICY IS BASED ON
PROTECTED CLASS SO ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WILL HAVE TO WE WILL
BE TRAINING OUR WORKFORCE IS
THAT.
IF YOU HAVE A DISCRIMINATION OR
HARASSMENT ISSUE SURROUNDING
THOSE ONE OF THOSE PROTECTED
CLASSES GENDER RACE THAT SORT OF
THING YOU WOULD COME INTO THIS
UNIT.
UMP BUT IF IT'S NOT ABOUT
PROTECTED CLASS IF YOU JUST
HAVE.
IF YOU'RE COMING IN CONTACT WITH
SOMEONE ON THE OUTSIDE ARE ON
THE INSIDE OF HIS YOU KNOW JUST
REALLY BEING A JERK AND YOU
DON'T FEEL SAFE.
YOU MAY BE REFERRED BACK TO
HUMAN RESOURCES OR SOMEWHERE
ELSE SO THAT'S WHY THE TRIAGE IS
REALLY IMPORTANT AND CERTAINLY
THE INSTRUCTION IS REALLY
IMPORTANT SO THAT PEOPLE WON'T
KNOW WHERE THE CORRECT PLACE TO
BRING.
RIGHT THERE INCIDENT TO SO THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING THAT
THANK YOU FOR WORK.
IF IF I MIGHT MISTER CHAIR I
WOULD ADD ON SENATOR LAR I THINK
THE UNIQUENESS ABOUT --
THE PANEL RECOGNIZING THAT THE
PANEL ON WILL AND WILL NOT HEAR.
THE THE RESULTS OF
INVESTIGATIONS FOR STAFF AND
MEMBERS.
I'M HOPEFUL AND BEGIN TO SEND A
VERY STRONG MESSAGE TO STAFF.
THAT THIS THE WE ARE TRYING --
TO DEVELOP AND BUILD A SYSTEM
AND A CULTURE OF EQUITY --
WHERE --
THEY SHOULD FULLY EXPECT THAT
THIS PANEL WOULD HERE.
CASES INVOLVING MEMBERS TO AND
SO IT'S NOT A SEPARATE BUT EQUAL
KIND OF SCENARIO THE PANEL WILL
HEAR AS RESPONSIBLE TO RESPOND
FOR INVESTIGATIONS FOR EVERYBODY
[inaudible]
MISS WALDRON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
CO CHAIRS AND COMMITTEE --
BUT I'M SURE WE'LL BE TALKING
ABOUT THE MOTION THAN THERE ARE
IN THE RECOMMENDATIONS LATER IN
THE ONE OF THE LAST THE SECTION
FIVE OF OUR ACCEPTANCE OF THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS --
BUT I DO WANT TO MAKE A COUPLE
COMMENTS AND ASK FOR
CLARIFICATION ON ONE THING --
YOU KNOWN WHEN THIS ALL STARTED
--
WHEN?
PEOPLE CAME FORWARD AND IT WAS
HARD FOR PEOPLE TO COME FORWARD
AND THAT WAS SOMETHING WE
RECOGNIZED FROM THE GET GO THE
FACT THAT.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE A LOT OF
EMOTION WE HAD TESTIMONY WE
DON'T WITH ALL KINDS OF ISSUES
IN OUR FIRST ARTS SUBCOMMITTEE
THEN OUR BY CARAMEL COMMITTEE --
YOU KNOW THE VICTIMS.
IT'S ALL ABOUT THE VICTIMS ARE
REALLY YOU KNOW WHAT WE'VE TRIED
TO DO -- THE
FEAR YOU KNOW THE FEELINGS THAT
THEY WEREN'T BEING LISTENED.
TO THE FOLLOW UP.
EVEN EXISTENCE ARM OR
INCONSISTENT AT ALL BUT IT WAS
BASED ON THE FACT THAT WE HAD
OUR QUE IF POLICIES POLICIES
THAT DIDN'T INVOLVE WITH THE
TIMES WHICH YOU KNOW WE'RE
STARTING TO SEE ONE EVERYTHING
KIND OF BROKE LOOSE AND MEDIA
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY --
BUT WE CAN SAY THAT.
WE HAVE HEARD YOU WE'VE HEARD
THE VICTIMS.
I THINK OUR COMMITTEE.
REALLY THAT WAS [inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
WHAT THE WHOLE UNDERLYING
PREMISE OF IT --
WHILE NO POLICY IS PERFECT THE
SELECT COMMITTEE WORK TO
DEVELOP.
A POLICY --
UNIQUE TO OUR ORGANIZATION WHICH
HAS BEEN TOUGH TO DO WHERE VERY
UNIQUE IN OUR WAY --
THAT ADDRESSES THE ISSUES
BROUGHT TO US WITH THE INTENT TO
CREATE THAT SAFE WORK
ENVIRONMENT WORK ON THE CULTURE
CHANGES THE INTENT --
TO HAVE A HAVE A PLACE WHERE
PEOPLE COME TO WORK AND THEY
FEEL LISTEN TO RESPECTED VALUED
--
SO THAT. ONE OF THE ARGUMENTS
YOU HEAR ABOUT HOME SOMETIMES AS
WELL WHY WASN'T IT A BILL THAT
WENT TO THE GOVERNOR TO BE
SIGNED.
BUT CLEARLY YOU KNOW SENATOR
MITCHELL POINTED OUT THIS IS A
H. OUR POLICY.
AND I JUST WANTED.
TO MAYBE IF YOU COULD ELABORATE
ON WHY IT WAS IMPORTANT THAT IT
WAS AN HR POLICY VERSUS A BILL
BECAUSE THAT SEEMS TO BE AN
ARGUMENT OUT THERE.
IF I MAY MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH --
MISS WALDRON AND AND I THINK I
WOULD I WOULD ADD TO YOUR
COMMENT YES THAT WE NOT ONLY
HEARD FROM VICTIMS [inaudible]
BUT WE FRAMED AGENDAS AND ALL OF
US TOGETHER SPENT THE TIME TO
HEAR FROM SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS.
AND SO WE DIDN'T --
BRING OUR OWN INDIVIDUAL.
LEGISLATIVE BRILLIANCE TO THE
TABLE.
WE SPENT HOURS HEARING FROM
PEOPLE WHO DO THIS WORK EVERY
DAY.
FROM --
EMPLOYMENT ATTORNEYS FROM THE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM SHARM THE
NATIONAL INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
FOR HUMAN RESOURCES
PROFESSIONALS --
SO WE HEARD FROM VICTIMS AND WE
HEARD FROM THE PEOPLE WHO DO
THIS WORK EVERY DAY.
THAT TOGETHER HELPED INFORM THE
FRAMEWORK OF A POLICY THAT'S
BEFORE YOU --
WE ARE AN EMPLOYER.
AND WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
DEVELOP H. OUR POLICIES TO
GOVERN OUR WORK AS EMPLOYERS
THAT IMPACT EMPLOYEES.
AND THE NATURE OF THE WORK WE DO
IS LEGISLATIVE.
BUT WE ARE EMPLOYERS AND WE
THOUGHT IT WAS IMPORTANT FOR US
IT AND WE WE SHOULD AND CAN AS
EMPLOYER STEP UP AND DEVELOP A
POLICY TO GOVERN OUR HR
PRACTICES --
WE SHOULDN'T GET IN THE PRACTICE
OF LEGISLATING A EVERY ACTION WE
HAVE TO TAKE AS EMPLOYERS WE
DON'T LEGISLATE OUR BENEFIT
PACKAGE WE DON'T LEGISLATE.
ARE WHAT YOU EAT YOU KNOW EVEN
THOUGH OUR OUR BUDGET IS FINITE
--
BUT WE DON'T LEGISLATE HR
PRACTICES ACROSS THE BOARD.
LEGISLATING APPROPRIATE IS THE
WORK WE DO.
AS EMPLOYERS WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO CREATE A SAFE
WORKPLACE TO TO DEVELOP POLICIES
THAT GUIDE OUR OUR PRACTICES OF
EMPLOYERS THIS IS NO DIFFERENT.
IT'S IMPORTANT --
ARE NEW FOCUS ON REINVIGORATED
IN REFOCUSING OUR CORPORATE
CULTURE IS IMPORTANT BUT IT'S
NOT ALL LEGISLATIVE LEAD.
MANDATE IT IT'S WHAT WE SHOULD
DO AS EMPLOYERS THERE MAY BE AS
WE DEVELOP THE FRAMEWORK --
POTENTIALLY I DON'T KNOW FOR
SURE ACTIONS WE NEED TO TAKE
LEGISLATIVELY --
TO OPERATIONALIZE THE POSSIBLY
PUT IN PLACE BUT THIS IS AN H.
OUR POLICY THAT WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO DEVELOP --
AND IT HERE TOO AS EMPLOYERS.
VERYGOOD OKAY --
MISTER MCGUIRE SENATOR MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH A FILE AND SAY
THANK YOU AND CHAIRMAN AND
CULTURE THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK
ALONG WITH COMMITTEE AND OF
COURSE.
VERY CAPABLE STAFF A BRING
FORTIES RECOMMENDATIONS I THINK
THIS IS.
A GIANT STEP FORWARD.
NOT FOR THE LEGISLATURE --
IN ENSURING THAT THERE IS DUE
PROCESS.
AND CANDIDLY PROTECTING THE
STAFF OF THE LEGISLATURE AS
WELL.
A UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCE IN THIS
MAY BE AN ITEM OUT LATER FOR
DIANE BOYD VINE.
ON SO WHEN WE HAD THESE
INCIDENTS.
BREAK A EARLIER THIS YEAR.
US ATTORNEYS CONTACTED
[inaudible]
THE STAFF.
WHO WERE OUTSIDE ATTORNEYS?
REPRESENTING OTHER JURISDICTIONS
--
AND THE STAFF. ONE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO INTERVIEW THEM ON RECORD
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED.
I AS WE ALL KNOW A STAFF
PARTICULARLY IF THEY ARE NEW TO
THIS BUILDING --
OUR CHALLENGED WITH THEIR
FINANCES [inaudible]
AND WHERE I WORKED PRIOR TO THIS
THE COUNTY CINEMA.
BECAUSE IT WAS A UNIONIZED I'M
[inaudible]
COUNTY.
THAT THEY WERE.
THAT BAD AT THEIR ELIGIBLE FOR
LEGAL REPRESENTATION AND NOT
HAVING TO BE A GOING TO AN
INTERVIEW OR DEPOSITION.
WITHOUT LEGAL REPRESENTATION.
ONE ITEM I WOULD SAY AS WE MOVE
FORWARD --
BECAUSE THERE WILL BE OTHER.
EVENTS LIKE WE SAW IN THE PAST.
HOW WERE ABLE? TO ENSURE THAT
STAFF HAS PROPER LEGAL
REPRESENTATION.
PRIOR TO GOING INTO A INTERVIEW
FORMAL INTERVIEW WITH A UP
POTENTIAL ALL USES.
A WITH ALL DUE RESPECT HOSTILE
ATTORNEY WHO IS REPRESENTING A
CLIENT [inaudible]
ON WHERE.
I HARASSMENT MADE TAKEN PLACE.
AND IT WAS THANKS TO OUR OUTSIDE
COUNSEL SOME WONDERFUL WOMEN
FROM THE THIRD HOUSE.
WHO HELPED A SOME OF THE WOMEN
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE THAT
PROVIDED EVENTUALLY A LEGAL
REPRESENTATION?
I JUST BRING THAT FORWARD
BECAUSE I THINK THAT IS AN ITEM
THAT WERE EVENTUALLY CAN HAVE TO
TACKLE BECAUSE SPENDING FOUR
HUNDRED DOLLARS AN HOUR. FOR
LEGISLATIVE AIDE TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE LEGAL REPRESENTATION.
IT'S GONNA BE A CHALLENGE AS WE
MOVE FORWARD AYE IN AGAIN.
JUST WANNA SAY THANK YOU FOR
THAT NETWORK AT EACH.
THROUGH EMPLOYEE ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM EACH EMPLOYEE CURRENTLY
RECEIVES ONE HOUR CONSULTATION
BUT ON THAT IS CURRENTLY IT SO
THAT'S JUST ONE ITEM.
JUST WANT TO GET BETTER FOR
CLARIFICATION --
IT IS OUR EXPECTATION --
THE WAY IT'S FRAME BASED ON THE
EXPERIENCE OF OTHERS THAT THE
INDEPENDENT UNIT.
THAT WE ARE NOW BUILDING AS A
RESULT THAT THAT WILL SERVE --
BOTH HOUSES.
WILL HAVE TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE AND THE
LION'S SHARE OF THE
INVESTIGATIONS.
BUT IF IT'S JUST BEING CANDID
CULMINATING AT LONDON'S ON THE
LINE HERE OF THE INVESTIGATIONS
YES WE ARE CLEAR THAT FOR SOME
INVESTIGATIONS WILL STILL HAVE
TO GO OUTSIDE COUNSEL --
THIS POLICY ASYLUM ON THAT THAT
IS A NEW ISSUE THAT WILL AGAIN
PUT IN THE AND THE PARKING LOT I
BOTH HOUSES PERHAPS IS COMMITTEE
WILL NEED TO ADDRESS BUT IT'S
NOT AN ISSUE THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT.
ON IN BUILDING THIS NEW POLICY.
OUR DESIRE WAS.
TO WHEN AT ALL POSSIBLE BRING
INVESTIGATIONS BACK IN HOUSE.
WE HAVE A BIT OF A KNEE JERK
REACTION OVER THE LAST YEAR.
AND BASICALLY FARMED EVERYTHING
OUT EXTERNALLY.
IN OUR EFFORT TO GIVE THE IT.
IT HEIGHTENED PUBLIC CONFIDENCE
ABOUT THE TRANSPARENCY
INVALIDITY OF THE INVESTIGATIONS
WE'RE CLEAR BASALLY EXPERTS WE
HAVE TALKED TO A THAT WE CAN AND
SHOULD AND THEREFORE ARE
PROPOSING.
AN IN HOUSE INDEPENDENT UNIT.
BUT AGAIN WE HOPE WILL DO THE
LINE SHARE SO WE'VE HEARD YOU IT
WAS NOT A PART OF THE POLICY AT
THAT'S DEATHLESS AT THAT WILL
HAVE TO CONSIDER NO NINE AND I
APPRECIATE IT VERY WHERE ABOUT
THE IN THE INDEPENDENT UNIT --
JUST GONNA BE CANDID SACRAMENTO
STATE [inaudible]
HAD ATTORNEYS THEY WERE
INTERVIEWING SENATE STAFF.
AND ARE SENATE STAFF.
I WENT COULD POTENTIALLY GOING
TO THESE INTERVIEWS [inaudible]
I'M REPRESENTED THAT'S I
UNDERSTAND YOU'RE GONNA COVER
THAT I JUST WANNA SAY THANK YOU
ADD OR TAKE AWAY FROM THE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT'S ONE ITEM
AS WE GO FORWARD I'VE BEEN ABLE
TO TAKE A LOOK AT THAT THAT MEN
CHAIRMAN OF CO CHAIR THANK YOU
FOR THE WONDERFUL WORK ALONG
WITH THE COMMITTEE.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU CENTER
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
SENATE MITCHELL.
US SENATOR MORAL AND COMMISSION
CHAIRMAN AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU.
FOR OBSERVING THE MEETINGS AND
AND BEING IN THE ROOM I REALLY
[inaudible]
IMPRESSED --
AND AND SINCE YOU WERE THERE --
WE DID HAVE A LOT OF WITNESSES
ATTACKING WHAT WE'RE DOING OR
WHAT WAS BEING PROPOSED HERE.
AB BUT IT SEEMS TO BE A
WHISPERING CAMPAIGN IN THE
MEDIA.
AND SO ARE YOU ARE YOU YOU HAVE
GIVEN US A LETTER [inaudible]
WILL THIS.
INDIVIDUAL BE PRESENTING UNDER
PUBLIC COMMENTS.
THAT WILL BE ENTERED INTO THE
RECORD THE ACID BE ENTERED IN
THE RECORD AT CLOSING HIM UNTIL
WE WILL.
PRO WE WILL DO THAT.
OF CAM JUST.
CURIOUS DE I HAVE HAVE HAVE YOU
SEEN THE LETTER THAT WE
RECEIVED.
OR MAYBE JUST FOR I JUST SAW FOR
THE FIRST TIME AS I WALKED INTO
THIS HEARING SO I HAVEN'T HAD
TIME TO ACTUALLY READ THE WHOLE
LETTER --
BUT WILL TAKE A LOOK AT IT WILL
BE ENTERED IN.
PUBLIC COMMENTS I JUST WANTED IT
MAYBE SOMEWHERE YOU MIGHT HAVE A
CHANCE JUST TO RESPOND BECAUSE
WE HAVE THAT IT IS.
WE TRIED TO ASK AS MANY
QUESTIONS OF THE BOTH OF YOU.
I THINK WE'VE DONE IT AND SO I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT.
WE FIGHT WOULD I DISPLAY HERE
FOR THE ME TOO MOVEMENT TO SAY
HEY WE WERE TRYING.
AND SO I THINK IT SHOULD BE JUST
ANOTHER LETTER THAT WE RECEIVED
I DON'T THIS NOT AS FAR AS I
KNOW IS HE HAS NO CONNECTION
WITH THE MEAT TO WOMEN WHO HAVE
WE'VE BEEN TALKING.
TO ABOUT THIS UP POLICY THEY
HAPPEN BRIEFED.
THEY HAVE PUBLICLY THROUGH
SOCIAL MEDIA EXPRESSED THEIR
GENERAL SUPPORT YOU KNOW I DON'T
SPEAK FOR THEM --
THEY WERE HERE ACTUALLY AT THE
LAST HEARING TOO YOU KNOW.
UGH UGH GIVE THEIR INPUT INTO
THE POLICY TO SOME EXTENT.
AND I'M SURE THEY'LL BE COULD
ONGOING CONVERSATIONS.
LETTER THAT YOU THAT THAT I SAW
DID NOT HAVE A CONNECTION AS FAR
AS I KNOW.
WITH -- ANY
MEANS THAT I DON'T THINK YOU
RECORDS REPRESENTED AS HAVING
ANY CONNECTION WITH THE ME TOO
I'M.
GROUP.
YOU FOR THE CLARIFICATION.
MAYBE WE'LL HEAR MORE UNDER
PUBLIC COMMENTS BUT I JUST
WANTED.
TO SEE IF YOU WANT TO DO IT
ADDRESSED LEASE THE POINTS OF
THIS.
ONE NOW.
BUT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR VERY
GOOD.
US CENTERS SKINNER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
APPRECIATION TO OUR CHAIRS AND
TO THE ENTIRE COMMITTEE FOR THE
WORKING TO THE STAFF.
MY QUESTION IS.
WE DIDN'T SO MUCH TALK ABOUT
WERE.
IN ITS NOT SO MUCH IN THE
POLICY.
AND I REALIZE THAT EACH SETTING
CAST TO BE --
EACH SITUATION [inaudible]
ON WOLF.
WHATEVER THE REMEDY IS WILL BE
UNIQUE TO THAT SITUATION BUT
WHAT I'M REFERRING TO US WHAT
[inaudible]
ONCE SOMETHING'S BEEN
INVESTIGATED.
AND IT SUSTAINED.
THAT WHAT THEN ARE THE
CONSEQUENCES AND WE TALKED A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT TRAINING SO
OBVIOUSLY WITHIN OUR OWN STAFF
--
THERE MAY BE --
SOME TYPE OF INTERVENTIONS LIKE
THAT BUT I WAS STRUCK BY.
THE EMPLOYEE SURVEY WHERE WOULD
INDICATE AT LEAST FROM THOSE WHO
RESPONDED TO THE SURVEY.
THAT THERE.
SEEMS TO BE A HIGHER INCIDENCE
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE EXTERNAL YES
SOME OTHER WORDS BEING HARASSED
BY A SALE LOBBYIST REPUBLIC NO
HARD BILLION HAVE CONSEQUENCES.
ON A PUBLIC IS A LITTLE
DIFFICULT TO HIM SAYING A
DISTRICT OFFICE IT WOULDN'T BE
IMPOSSIBLE FOR US TO IN EFFECT
BEYOND THEM FROM ATTENDING ART
TOO SHOWING UP AT OUR DISTRICT
OFFICES NEW --
BUT WITH LOBBYIST WHAT.
DID THE COMMITTEE DISCUSSED AT
ALL WHAT TYPE OF REAL REMEDIES.
WE MIGHT HAVE IN THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
WE WE DIDN'T HAVE MUCH OF A
DISCUSSION ABOUT THAT BECAUSE
FIRST OF ALL WITHOUT KNOWING
LEGALLY WHAT WE CAN AND CAN'T
DO.
I IT'S HARD TO HAVE THE
DISCUSSION AND WE YOU KNOW WE
JUST HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT THAT
YET CERTAINLY THAT'S A TOPIC FOR
ONGOING DISCUSSION I WILL SAY
THAT WE'VE HAD THE SUGGESTION
COME IN FROM SOME.
MEMBERS OF THE LOBBY CORPS.
THAT WOULD PERHAPS WE SHOULD
EXPLORE AND THIS IS GONNA SOUND
RADICAL AND I HOW I CAN JUST SAY
THIS WITHOUT HAVING SPOKEN TO
VERY MANY PEOPLE.
ASKING OF SOME OF THOSE
LOBBYISTS WOULD SUBJECT
THEMSELVES TO OUR PROCESS SO
THAT IF AN ALLEGATION OF AN
INCIDENT WAS REPORTED TO GET UP
FOR A LOBBYIST.
MAYBE THEY WOULD COME IN FRONT
OF THE SAME PANEL IN FRONT OF
OUR PANEL.
SO THAT'S A POSSIBILITY THAT
HAVE TO SUBJECT HIMSELF TO THAT
WILLINGLY WE CAN'T FORCE THEM.
TO THE PANEL CAN STILL
INVESTIGATE.
A CLAIM LIKE THAT --
BUT THAT WOULD DEPEND ON WHETHER
OR NOT THEY WOULD WANT TO
PARTICIPATE --
SOMETIMES YOU WANT THE OTHER
SIDE GIVING THEIR POINT YOU KNOW
THE WHAT THE SUBJECT TO BE ABLE
TO RESPOND WE CAN'T FORCE THEM
TO DO THAT THIS POINT.
BUT THESE ARE ALL THINGS TO BE
EXPLORED YOU KNOW GOING FORWARD.
SO THAT DOES RAISE.
CAN'T FORCE THEM.
WE WOULD STILL DO THE
INVESTIGATION BUT THEN WE WOULD
ONLY BE IF IF THE PERSON
ACCUSED.
DID NOT INTERACT WITH OUR
INVESTIGATORS WE WOULD ONLY HAVE
THE VERSION OF OUR OWN STAFF --
I I DON'T HAVE THE ANY ANSWER
BUT I IF IF IN FACT.
THERE IS SEE PLAY I DON'T WANT
TO EVEN SAY A HIGH LIKELIHOOD
RIGHT I JUST WANNA SAY IFS.
ENOUGH STAFF OF EXPERIENCE THAT
THAT THEY RESPONDED IN THE
SURVEY.
THEIR ABILITY TO FEEL SATISFIED.
THAT WE ARE CREATING A WORKPLACE
WHERE THEY CAN FEEL SAFE.
WE WILL NEED TO HAVE SOME KIND
OF YEP.
WE WE WILL IN AND I THINK EVEN
WITHOUT THE PARTICIPATION OF THE
SUBJECT OF AN INVESTIGATION IF
THE DISK WITH THE PANEL WERE
DETERMINED THAT THERE'S A HIGH
LIKELIHOOD THAT IN.
INCIDENT OR MULTIPLE INCIDENCES
OCCURRED --
THEREIN THERE AREN'T CURRENTLY.
I THINK THAT HAVE BEEN DONE AND
CAN BE DONE IN TERMS OF NOT
ALLOWING.
CERTAIN MEMBERS BE CERTAIN
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO GO TO
CERTAIN OFFICES --
THAT'S NOT BEEN UNHEARD OF IN
THIS BUILDING SO EVEN WITHOUT
THEIR PARTICIPATION THERE ARE
SOME.
SOME THERE SOME ABILITY WITH
WITH SOME --
PRETENSION OF EMPLOYEES --
THE BUT IN TERMS BUT YOU KNOW
AGAIN WITHOUT US KNOWING THE FOR
WITHOUT THE COMMITTEE HAVING
EXPORT THE FULL RANGE OF LEGAL
RESPONSES I COULDN'T TELL YOU
BUT BUT NOW WE KNOW FROM OUR
CLIMATE SURVEY THAT FIND OUT
WHAT GOES RANGERS ARE AND MAKE
SURE THAT IN POLICY.
WERE PREPARED SO THAT PEOPLE
AREN'T SCRAMBLING AT THE MOMENT
THAT REPORT COMES IN THAT WE
KNOW.
HOW THAT WILL BE INVESTIGATED
HOW WILL BE ADJUDICATED AND WHAT
THE POTENTIAL?
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS COULD BE
FROM PANEL BECAUSE THE ONLY TO
BE INFORMED AS WELL IF THERE'S A
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC HERE'S WHAT
YOU'RE.
HERE'S WHAT YOUR ABILITY IS TO
RECOMMEND SO WE'VE HEARD --
AND I THINK THAT LEGAL COUNSEL
HAS HEARD AS WE DEVELOP THIS
POLICY AND AS WE INSTRUCT OUR
NEW.
PANEL THEY'LL NEED TO KNOW WHAT
TOOLS THEY HAVE AT THEIR
DISPOSAL AS WELL SO.
IF I WOULD JUST THAT.
MISTER CHAIR I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT -- WE
HAD SOME CONVERSATION WE PRESENT
THE RESULTS OF THE CLIMATE
SURVEY TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE THERE
WOULD MEMBERS WHO EXPRESSED
CONCERN ABOUT THE 46% SPOT IT
RIGHT -- I
WOULD ARGUE --
THAT TO THOSE EMPLOYEES WHO
CHOSE NOT TO PARTICIPATE.
ON PI THINK --
ARE FOLLOW UP IN HANDLING OF AN
AND AN ISSUE THAT.
SURFACED AS A RESULT OF THE
CLIMATE SERBIAN THEM AS A RESULT
OF YOUR CAR CO WORKERS IN YOUR
FELLOW LET STAFF WHO DID
PARTICIPATE.
ALL HOPEFULLY WILL BE AN
INDICATION OF OUR COMMITMENT TWO
TAKING THE TEMPERATURE CHECK OF
LEGISLATIVE STAFF EXPERIENCE AND
DEVELOPING POLICIES AS A RESULT
--
THAT WAS VERY TELLING AND WE
JUST HAVE TO FIGURE OUT ITS NOT
BLACK OR WHITE.
ALL BUT WE ARE CLEAR THAT IT'S A
PROBLEM IN IN I THINK
COLLECTIVELY AS THE LEGISLATURE
WE HAVE A COMMITMENT TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT WE CAN'T DO WE JUST
DON'T HAVE IT YET.
BUT I HOPE THAT THAT ALL STAFF
WILL RECOGNIZE THE VALUE OF A
CLIMATE SURVEY IN COMMUNICATING
YOUR EXPERIENCES TO YOUR
EMPLOYER AND ALLOWING US THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO THEN RESPOND SO
WHAT ARE THE NEXT STEPS.
WOULD WE WAIT UNTIL THEY'RE
SAYING INCIDENT OF AN EXTERNAL
PERSON LEXUS USE AN EXAMPLE OF A
LOBBYIST OR LOBBYIST'S HARASSES.
SOMEONE IN THE BUILDING THE
BUILDING CODE THE PERSON THE
STAFFORD COMPLAINTS IT'S
INVESTIGATED.
AND WHETHER OR NOT THE LOBBYIST
--
PARTICIPATED OR NOT THE
INVESTIGATION FEELS THAT THE
THAT THE COMPLAINT IS
SUSTAINABLE [inaudible]
THAT CIRCUMSTANCE ONCE WE FACE
THAT THAT WE WOULD THINK ABOUT
COGNOS SO WE SO WHAT'S OUR NEXT
ABSENT IN TERMS OF IF I MAY ON
THAT WORD OBSERVATION JUST AS
SOMEONE WHO SAT THROUGH THEIR
HEARING.
IT BEFORE YOU GO SHOPPING.
I THINK THE POINTTHAT SENATOR
MITCHELL HIGHLIGHTED THE HIGH
LEVEL OF ENGAGEMENT OF OUR
POLICE CURRY BECOMES ACTION
ASSET TO OUR ORGANIZATION AS WE
TRY TO MOVE FORWARD.
WE'RE TRYING TO CREATE A A
REDIRECTION INSTITUTION REFORM
IN THE ROAD.
TAKE IN A DIFFERENT DIRECTION
AND I THINK THE HIGH LEVEL OF
ENGAGEMENT.
COUPLED WITH THE OBJECTIVE TO
FOCUS ON IMPLICIT BIAS TRAINING
BYSTANDER TRAINING.
REALLY WANT TO TAKE THAT
ENGAGEMENT AND HAVE EVERYONE
KIND OF OWN THESE ISSUES.
AND STARTED SO MY QUESTION JUDGE
IN SO MUCH AS TO WHETHER THE
EMPLOYEE FEEL SATISFIED AS MUCH
AS IT'S WHETHER WE HAVE A REMEDY
FOR THAT EXTERNAL.
HARASSER SO AT AT WHAT WE'RE
ASKING TODAY IS THAT THE
COMMITTEE CONSIDER AND AND VOTE
ON ON THE CURRENT RECOMMENDATION
WHICH IS THE CURRENT FRAMEWORK.
THE WORK IS NOT DONE.
AND SO THIS IS THIS IS A
FRAMEWORK OKAY THERE'S STILL
WORK THAT WILL HAVE TO ENGAGE AT
THE STAFF LEVEL --
AS WELL AS THROUGH THROUGH
GUIDANCE FROM --
A LEGISLATORS IN TERMS OF REALLY
PUTTING THE MEAT ON THE BONES
THIS IS A FALLS IN THE MEAT ON
THE BONES CATEGORY FOR ME AND
THE SKINNER.
SO IT'S NOT WE PASS THIS WE'RE
DONE.
A RACE NO LIES REALLY KIND OF
THE ASPIRATIONAL GOAL SET
FORWARD IN THIS FRAMEWORK.
SO SO FIGURING OUT BILL ARE ARE
LEGALLY TALES FOR EXACTLY
FIGURED OUT HOW FAR WE CAN GO A
LEGALLY IN TERMS OF DEALING WITH
EXTERNAL PEOPLE --
THAT WORK WHO IS GOING TO
CONTINUE APPRECIATE THAT
CLARIFICATION AND THEN CHAIR.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU ARE
EXPECTING A MOTION BUT AND AND
WHATEVER POINT I WILL MOVE THE
COMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDATIONS.
WILL TAKE A LITTLE MORE A FEW
MORE QUESTIONS WE'RE GONNA HEAR
FROM ARE LESS SAFE COUNSEL WHO
WILL GET TO THE POINT OF A
MOTION.
AND IT MAY FALL TO ONE OF OUR
SHARES OF ARE GOING TO BE FINE.
BEHIND AND BY THE WAY THAT THE
POINT YOU BRING UP IS REALLY
IMPORTANT AND I THINK THAT PART
OF THIS IS WHEN YOU MAKE A POINT
LIKE THAT IN EVERY OF THE SORT
OF GENERAL CONSENSUS HERE.
THEIR HEARING US THAT
LEGISLATIVE COUNCILS THEY
DEVELOP THIS YOU'RE HEARING US
AND KNOW THAT THAT'S WHAT A PART
OF WHAT WE'RE ASKING THEM. TO
NOW FLUSH OUT AND I THINK THAT
THEY'VE HEARD VERY CLEARLY FROM
SEVERAL OF YOU THAT THAT POINT
ABOUT.
WHAT WE DO WITH OUTSIDE PEOPLE
IS IMPORTANT THAT THEY NEED TO
REALLY --
MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THE POLICY IN
THAT IT'S PUT IN PLACE AS SOON
AS WE CAN SO THAT IT'S READY TO
GO IF AN INCIDENT LIKE THAT
SHOULD COMMON [inaudible]
SENATOR ROTH.
YOU MISTER CHAIR --
DURING THE PRESENTATION YOU.
I'VE KNOWLEDGE THAT OBVIOUSLY --
ES COMPLAINTS COMMENCEMENT WILL
PERTAIN TO HARASSMENT
DISCRIMINATION AND SOME WILL NOT
SO AS WE YOU WE TRIAGE.
THESE COMPLAINTS AND
COMPLAINANTS AND REFER THEM.
BETWEEN THE YEAR THE INDEPENDENT
UNIT AND HR OR PERHAPS SOME
OTHER OFFICE.
THERE'S ALWAYS GOING TO BE THE
RISKS THAT --
SOME WILL DROP TO THE CRACKS.
SO I GUESS MY QUESTIONS ARE --
TO ONE HOW HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT
THAT DOES NOT HAPPEN AND TO WHO
DO WE HOLD ACCOUNTABLE.
FOR MAKING SURE THAT THE
COMPLAINANT SMOOTHLY TRANSITION
IN THE PROCESS BETWEEN THE
INDEPENDENT UNIT.
OF THE VARIOUS HR OFFICES AND
PERHAPS SOME OTHER OFFICE THAT
SET UP.
IT'S A GREAT QUESTION SO THAT
WHENEVER AN INCIDENT COMES INTO
THE UNIT --
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
AMERICAN NATION IS THAT IT'S THE
PANEL ITSELF THAT ACTUALLY
EVALUATES EACH OF THESE TAKES A
LOOK AT IT AND SAYS SOMETHING
THAT THEY MIGHT SEE SOMEONE LIKE
YOU KNOW WHAT EVEN IF THIS IS
ALL TRUE THIS DOES NOT FALL
UNDER OUR PURVIEW THIS REALLY.
NEEDS TO GO TO HR BECAUSE THIS
IS JUST PEOPLE NOT GETTING ALONG
OR WHATEVER IT IS.
SO THE PANEL WOULD BE THE ONE TO
WHETHER THEY ARE GOING TO BE
HEARING THE CASE DURING THE
INCIDENT ADJUDICATING IT OR
WHETHER IT'S GOING TO GO BACK TO
HR ONCE THEY SEND IT OFF.
I WOULD EXPECT THIS SORT OF THAT
THAT HR IF IT GOES TO HR THAT
BILL ON THE DO WHATEVER FOLLOW
UP EVALUATION THEY NEED TO DO
AND THEN THEY'LL NEED TO ISSUE A
LETTER AT SOME POINT TO THE
COMPLAINING PARTY.
WHERE THE REPORTING PARTY TO AS
WE SAID THAT THAT RESPONSE BACK
TO THE PERSON WHO REPORTS THE
INCIDENT IS VERY IMPORTANT AND
MY RECOMMENDATION WOULD BE THAT
IT'S NOT JUST?
THIS INDEPENDENT UNIT THAT DOES
THAT KIND OF RESPONSE THAT HR
ALSO IS TASKED WITH RESPONDING
ON EACH UNIT LIKE THAT THAT
COMES INTO.
MY EACH INCIDENT THAT COMES AND
I ASSUME THAT IS WE WE'RE NOT
SETTING UP A DETAILED PROCEDURES
HERE IN IS THE DETAILED
PROCEDURES ARE SET UP.
WILL BE A TRACKING MECHANISM SO
THICK SO A COMPLAINT AND THE
COMPLAINT IT CAN BE TRACKED
THROUGH THE PROCESS WHETHER IT'S
FROM THE INDEPENDENT.
UNIT TWO HR TO HR TO SOME OTHER
OFFICE AND SO AT THE END OF THE
DAY.
WHOEVER IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS
SIZE SUMAR LEADERSHIP WILL BE
ABLE TO TRACK A COMPLAINT
WHETHER IT'S APPROPRIATE TO BE
HANDLED AT THE INDEPENDENT UNIT
OR THE UNIT DETERMINE THE
DETERMINES THAT IT'S NOT AND
REFERS TO COMPLAIN THAT HR.
THERE'S A TRACKING AND THEN
THERE'S AN OUTCOME AND THERE'S A
TIME LINE AND ALL THAT SO
ABSOLUTELY AND SINCE IT DIDN'T
COME UP ALSO MENTIONED THAT
THESE COMPLAINTS THAT DO COME
INTO THE UNIT THAT ARE
SUBSTANDARD ARE SUSTAIN THEY
WILL BE KEPT TO MEAN THOSE
RECORDS WILL BE RETAINED.
SO THAT OVER TIME --
WITH THEY'LL HAVE THE ABILITY TO
SEE IF PARTICULAR EMPLOYEES ARE
HAVING AN UNUSUALLY HIGH NUMBER
OF ALLEGATIONS EVEN IF THEY'RE
NOT SUSTAIN PROFOUND.
OKAY PERFECT NATURE OF THANK YOU
MISTER.
VERY GOOD --
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
--
AND DO YOU HAVE A COMPUTER
REMARKS RURAL.
TRANSITION TO DYNAMIC WHERE
WIRELESS CHIEF COUNSEL. FOR THE
NEXT STEP AND THEN PUBLIC
COMMENT AND AT ACTION.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU OF COURSE.
OUR CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR AND ALL
THE PANEL MEMBERS FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS.
MS BOYER VINE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS AND THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY I
BROUGHT WITH ME MY ACTING CHIEF
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER.
IF WE END UP GETTING INTO THE
WEEDS AND ANYTHING --
I WANNA THANK YOU FOR AND
TRUSTING TO THE OFFICE THIS --
EFFORT TO ASSIST INSURING THAT
YOU HAVE AN INDEPENDENT PROCESS
IN HANDLING THESE WORKPLACE
HARASSMENT COMPLAINTS.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE NEW
pWHAT STEPS IT'S GOING TO TAKE
TO
GET TO JUST.
THAT THE KIND OF BARE BONES AND
YOU ASK A LOT OF REALLY GOOD
QUESTIONS IN THIS HEARING THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION AS WE MOVE
FORWARD.
ON MY UNDERSTANDING IS THE GOAL
IS TO HAVE THIS IN PLACE BY
EARLY.
TWENTY NINETEEN AND SO THERE ARE
SEVERAL STEPS ALONG THE WAY.
I BREAK THOSE DOWN INTO
CATEGORIES --
THOSE OUR STATUTORY
AUTHORIZATION PERSONNEL
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
FACILITIES AND BUDGET.
A IF -- WE
AREN'T THE OPINION THAT WE NEED
STATUTORY AUTHORIZATION TO BE
ABLE TO ENCOMPASS THIS UNIT WITH
AND OTHER WORK AT THE OFFICE OF
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL AND SO WE'VE
BEEN PREPARING BILL LANGUAGE FOR
INTRODUCTION.
IN AUGUST ON IN TERMS OF
PERSONNEL YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER
THAT THE OFFICE LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL IS A CIVIL SERVICE
AGENCY.
SO WE MUST FOLLOW THE RULES THAT
ARE PUT IN PLACE BY CAL HR IN
OUR PROCESS OF HIRING FOLKS.
HAVING SAID THAT WE'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS --
SINCE HE LEARNED ABOUT THE LA
COUNTY MODEL WE TALK ABOUT
WORKLOAD WAS --
WITHIN YOUR HR UNITS.
AND DECIDED THAT.
THE LEVEL OF STAFFING WE WOULD
NEED WOULD BE AN ATTORNEY
MANAGER FOR THE WORKPLACE
CONDUCT UNIT TO ATTORNEY
INVESTIGATORS A SUPPORT STAFF
AND OF COURSE YOUR FIVE ON PANEL
MEMBERS --
THE MANAGER WOULD BE APPOINTED
BY USING ONE OF THE TWO EXAMPLE
SESSIONS OF THE OFFICE OF
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL HAS SO THAT
MAKES IT A LITTLE EASIER TO GO
THROUGH THE PROCESS.
WE STILL HAVE TO GO BACK TO
COLLEGE TURN YET SEEM RE
CLASSIFICATION OF THE POSITION
TO THE LEVEL WE'RE GOING TO
APPOINT THE PERSON AT AND THEN
AFTER THAT WE WOULD HAVE TO
RECRUIT FOR THAT POSITION.
INTERVIEW THE APPLICANTS AND
THEN HIRE THE MANAGER IT'S THE
GOAL TO GET THAT MANAGER IN
PLACE FIRST TO HELP US THEN
BUILD OUT THE REST OF THIS UNIT.
IN ADDITION TO THE MANAGER WE
WOULD HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE
HIRING PROCESS FOR THE TWO
SENIOR ATTORNEY IS --
WHO WE WOULD ANTICIPATE WOULD
HAVE EMPLOYMENT LAW EXPERIENCE
AND ONE CLERICAL STAFF PERSON?
AND THEN FINALLY ONCE THE PANEL
MEMBERS ARE SELECTED BY.
THIS BODY THROUGH THE PROCESS --
WE WOULD PREPARE THE CONTRACTS
FOR THOSE PANEL MEMBERS MY
UNDERSTANDING IS AN ALLEY COUNTY
THIS PANEL MEMBERS ARE UNDER
CONTRACT SO WE WOULD HAVE.
A YEAR CONTRACT --
WITH A BASE AMOUNT THAT THEY
WOULD WORK AGAINST.
A I'VE ASKED THE LEGISLATIVE
DATA CENTER TO WORK ON THE
INFAMOUS NATION TECHNOLOGY NEEDS
AT A MINIMUM THERE NEEDS TO BE A
FIREWALL BETWEEN MY LITIGATION
ATTORNEYS AND THIS PANEL BECAUSE
WE REPRESENT.
MEMBERS AND STAFF IN THERE ARE
LITIGATION MATTERS THAT COME OUT
OF THE SEXUAL HARASSMENT
COMPLAINTS.
WE'RE GOING TO NEED A REPORTING
WEBSITE HOTLINE AND A CASE
MANAGEMENT TOOL SENATOR ROTH
ALLUDED TO TO TRACK COMPLAINTS
INVESTIGATIONS RECOMMENDATIONS
AND FINAL DISCIPLINE.
I THE UNIT HAS TO BE HOUSE
SOMEWHERE DOWN TOWN AND
SACRAMENTO CURRENTLY THE OFFICE
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL HAS SPACE
ELEVEN HUNDRED JAY STREET AND
NINE TWENTY FIVE L. STREET.
SO WE'RE LOOKING FOR ADDITIONAL
SPACE WITHIN THE VICINITY OF THE
CAPITOL IN LOOKING FOR THAT
SPACE WERE AWARE OF THE NEED TO
HAVE A SENSE OF CONFIDENTIALITY
FOR FOLKS WHO ARE COMING THERE.
AND ALSO OF SECURITY FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE WORKING IN THE
SPACE SO TO FIND THAT RIGHT
SPACE NEGOTIATE A LEASE.
A MAYBE MAKE TENANT IMPROVEMENTS
CAN TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF TIME
BUT WE'VE ALREADY ENGAGED OR
BROKER TO LOOK FOR SPACE AND
ACTUALLY SAW SOME PRETTY GOOD
SPACE LAST FRIDAY THAT.
MIGHT WORK OUT --
FINALLY THEY'LL HAVE TO BE AN
ARGUMENT AUGMENTATION TO THE
BUDGET AND THAT AUGMENTATION
RECOVER ALL OF THE ADDITIONAL
SALARIES AND THE OPERATING
EXPENSES AND THE TECHNOLOGY FOR
THE UNIT.
THAT'S A QUICK FIVE MINUTE OVER.
BRIEF IT BRIEFING OF THIS AND
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
ANY QUESTIONS MANY MEMBERS
[inaudible]
YES.
ZERO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
JUST WANTED TO KNOW A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT.
PROCESS AND I DON'T KNOW IF THIS
IS THE END OF THE PRESENTATION.
FROM YOUR END OR IT IS.
WHO OKAY OKAY?
THEN LET'S GET INTO THE WEEDS A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT.
FIDUCIARY RESPONSIBILITY SHARE
--
HOW DOES THAT WORK EXACTLY --
IF YOU ARE GOING TO BE
CONDUCTING THIS INVESTIGATION
AND THOROUGH VETTING.
WHO DO YOU RESPOND?
TO HOW DOES IT WORK SO THAT'S
ONE HOW DOES IT WORK IF A MEMBER
COMES TO YOU VERSES A STAFFER
[inaudible]
NO.
SO --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN THIS AREA TWO
OKAY.
RIGHT TIME BUT THAT'S OKAY AND
AND I'M AND I HAVE A THOROUGH
BUT WHY DON'T I ALLOW YOU TO
START.
ANSWERING AND THEN ALL.
SENATOR HANNAH IS GOING TO BE
INDEPENDENT OF I'M NOT GOING TO
BE CONDUCTING THE INVESTIGATION
JOE HAVE A PROCESS WHERE THERE'S
INTAKE.
UNTIL BE INTAKE ATTORNEYS AN
INTAKE CLERICAL STAFF THEY WILL
TRIAGE AS WE TALKED ABOUT BEFORE
THEY THEN THE ATTORNEYS WILL
INVESTIGATE THE FACTS.
GET THE FACTS GATHERED FOR THE
PANEL MEMBERS WAY UNDERSTAND
WORKS IN LA AND THEN THE PANEL
MEMBERS WILL MAKE THE
DETERMINATION WILL FULL ACCESS
THOSE FACTS.
THE SITE YOU ASSESS WITNESSES
DECIDE WHETHER THIS IS BEEN
SUBSTANTIATED.
AND WHETHER THERE'S A LEVEL OF
DISCIPLINE THEY WOULD
RECOMMEND-AND BACK TO THE
INDIVIDUAL RULES
COMMITTEES.
PUT THAT AND LET LET ME BACK UP
A LITTLE BIT MISS BOYER VINE IS
USING THE TERM ATTORNEYS WE'VE
USED THE TERM INVESTIGATORS WILL
WE TALKED ABOUT THE UNIT.
AND SO I JUST THINK FOR
CONSISTENT IT SAYS SINCE HE LEFT
THE INVESTIGATOR FOR THE THIRD
UNIT.
OKAY AND AND IT WOULD BE INTO.
LET'S COUNSEL AND SO WHEN YOU
SAY IF IT IS YOUR RESPONSIBILITY
MEAN WHO PAYS FOR THE UNIT. ONE
THAT THAT PLAYS IN THE
LEGISLATURE A ROLE AS WELL THE
LEGISLATURE OKAY SO THEN THEIR
FIRST RESPONSE BACK IS GOING TO
BE.
TO THE LEGISLATIVE BODY OR TWO
RULES COMMITTEE.
WHO EXACTLY SO --
IN EUROPE FOLDER YOU SHOULD HAVE
A POWER POINT THAT WE WALK
THROUGH THAT TALKS ABOUT NOT
ONLY THE BEST TO GET TO VIEW IT.
BUT ALSO THIS INDEPENDENT PANEL
THAT WE ARE PROPOSING ALSO.
AND THAT IF THE INVESTIGATION
WARRANTS.
THE THE PANEL WITHIN DETERMINE
AND TAKE ACTION THERE ARE
INSTANCES WHERE IT DOESN'T WANT
GOING TO THE PANEL IT WOULD GO
BACK TO THE RESPECTIVE HOT ROUTE
RULES COMMITTEES [inaudible]
OKAY.
I'M JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
CHAIR I HOPE.
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME OF AND
THE LATITUDE I'M JUST TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT TO WHAT EXTENT THE
INVESTIGATION HAS ITS OWN
ABILITY.
TO PROCEED.
AND NOW IT'S IT'S SO MUCH OF
WHAT WE DO IS.
BASED ON ALSO THE CREDIBILITY
THAT WERE ABLE TO OPERATE IN.
SO THAT'S THAT'S WHAT I WAS
TRYING TO GET AT SO SO THE THE
OUR DESIRE IN CREATING THIS NEW
BICAMERAL INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATIVE UNIT.
IS TO REALLY DO OTHER THINGS IS
TO IS TO GIVE US ALL THE
CONFIDENCE THAT WE HAVE TRAINED
SKILLED INVESTIGATORS.
WHO FOR THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
CASES -- CAN
TAKE THEM IF YOU WILL FROM SOUP
TO NUTS --
AND THAT THAT POINT LET'S
INVESTIGATION IS DONE AND THEY
HAVE A REPORT --
CAN THEN TAKE IT PROVIDED TO THE
PANEL.
WHO WILL HEAR IT AND MAKE A
DETERMINATION?
AND THAT RECOMMENDATION WILL GO
TO RULES COMMITTEE [inaudible]
OR IF INDEED IT JUST NEEDS TO GO
BACK TO THE INDIVIDUAL --
HR DEPARTMENTS IN BOTH HOUSES.
FOR THE NEXT STEP.
AND IN JUST THE LAST QUESTION
GOING BACK TO THE IF A COMPLAINT
COMES FROM A STAFFER IN GOES
DIRECTLY TO ONE OF THE ATTORNEYS
AND AND OR THAT THE
INVESTIGATORS --
JUST.
MAINTAINING THE SANCTITY OF THE
PROCESS HOW WILL THAT.
THE COMMUNICATION FROM THE
INVESTIGATOR WOULD BE DIRECTLY
WITH THAT STAFFER THAT'S CORRECT
AND SO NOTHING IS GONNA BE --
THERE'S GOING TO BE NO OTHER
INTERVENTION.
THAT'S CORRECT IN THAT PROCESS
[inaudible]
CORRECT PICKUP [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD TO US THANK YOU.
I AM BLESSED COUNCIL TIME OR
FIND.
WE'LL NOW TAKE PUBLIC TESTIMONY
A WRITTEN TEST ONE WHO SUBMITTED
THIS MORNING BY --
JOHN BYRNE AND THAT.
DISPLAY HAS BEEN SUBMITTED THE
JOINT COMMITTEE ON RULES AND IS
HEREBY ENTERED IN THE RECORD HAS
BEEN DISTRIBUTED --
OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY.
PLEASE APPROACH THE MIKE AND
THIS ONE I SAW A SHOOTING A
MISTER CHAIRMAN BROWSING.
FORGIVE ME BUT I WILL HAVE TO
LEAVE BEFORE.
WAITING FOR ALL THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY I JUST WANTED TO LET
THE COMMITTEE KNOW IF YOU LOOK
AT THE OUR PROPOSED --
MOTION UNDER OF ONE BE HA I HAVE
HAD A DISCUSSION WITH OUR CHAIR
WOMEN.
ARE REGARDING WHEN WE'RE SAY
REPORT AND WE'RE LEAVING GOING
TO LEAVE THAT DISCRETION --
GOING FORWARD TO WHAT REPORT
SOME OF THOSE THAT ARE REALLY
MINOR AS WE DISCUSS FOR SOMEONE
USES AN INAPPROPRIATE TERM.
IN DISCUSSING WITH YOU KNOW ONE
OF THE OF STAFFERS ARE SOME OF
THOSE WILL BE MINOR AND NOT
NECESSARILY PART OF A REPORT
THAT.
I CERTAINLY AGREE WITH THE CHAIR
WOMAN THAT.
IN IN THAT AREA SO ENSURE VOTING
ON THIS --
CHAIRWOMAN MAY WANT TO ELABORATE
ON THAT BUT I CERTAINLY AGREE
BECAUSE IT WAS.
ON THE MEN THAT WE PROPOSED IN
THE SUB COMMITTEE SO THAT
EVERYONE IS RECEIVING THE REPORT
AT THE SAME TIME AND THERE CAN'T
BE ANY SUSPICION THAT FROM THE
BURIED SOMEBODY.
YOU KNOW THE INVESTIGATIVE
REPORT ON AN INDIVIDUAL IN
PARTICULAR MEMBERS OF OUR
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE
EYESIGHT AND MAKE THAT CLEAR
BECAUSE I WILL HAVE TO LEAVE AND
THEN IF YOU WILL THE ROLE OF
PANICKING.
SCOTT.
HOW TO ADD MY TWO CENTS THAT?
NO I THINK THAT THANK YOU.
CENTER BATES.
I THINK OF THIS ADDITION IS.
REALLY TO MAKE CLEAR THAT ONE
THERE WHEN A REPORTERS BEEN
DONE.
AND IT IS OF CONSEQUENCE ILL GO
THE FULL SENATE RULES COMMITTEE
AGO THE CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR OF
THE ASSEMBLY.
ASSEMBLY RULES COMMITTEE SO
THERE'S NO POSSIBILITY THAT ONE
PARTY GETS IT THE OTHER PARTY
DOESN'T.
I SEE THAT IS TRYING.
TO CONFRONT THIS ISSUE OF POWER
REDUCE POWER MAY THINGS GO AWAY.
AND AND SO I THINK THAT IS A
TRUST OF THOSE CHANGES I THINK
YOU'RE QUITE CONSTRUCTIVE.
I THINK THE POINT YOU RAISE IN
THAT.
NOT EVER REPORT BAY ELEVATOR
THAT LEVEL IS SOMETHING THAT MAY
BE SEVEN FIND AS TIME GOES ON
BUT I THINK.
IN THAT SENSE THE USE OF THE
WORD REPORT THAT SAID IN HIS A
SMALL POINT.
AS COMPARED THIS LARGER ONE OF
MAKING SURE THAT IT IS A BI
PARTISAN DISCLOSURE OF THE
FINDING.
BECAUSE THAT ACTUALLY GOES TO
THE FUNDAMENTAL DYNAMIC.
THAT IS AN OUT WORKING OF THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE PROCESS --
SO THANK YOU FOR THAT
OBSERVATION [inaudible]
AND SO WHAT THAT --
HERE'S WHAT DISAPPEARS IDENTIFY
YOURSELF AND TAKE A JOINT HOUSE.
YES --
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
POLITICS READ ON BEHALF APOLOGY
--
ONE OF THE CO FOUNDERS THE
ORIGINAL FOUNDERS OF WE SAID
ENOUGH.
SO FIRST FALL I WANTED TO THANK
BOTH CO CHAIRS FOR THEIR HARD
WORK.
LEADERSHIP OF BOTH HOUSES BOTH
RULES COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
THIS WAS YEOMAN'S WORK IT WAS A
TIRED TIRED TIRELESS AND
THANKLESS IT SOMETIMES BUT I
KNOW THAT YOU DID A INCREDIBLE
JOB -- ON
BEHALF OF WE SAID ENOUGH I'D
LIKE.
TO READ SOMETHING INTO THE FILE
THAT -- AND
SAY THAT WE STAND READY TO HELP
WE SAID ENOUGH STANDS READY TO
HELP -- WE
WANT TO KEEP THE VOICES OF THE
VICTIMS.
CONVERSATION ILLINOIS ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS ABOUT INCLUDING
LOBBYISTS.
AND WE WANT TO HELP BUILD TRUST
IN THE PROCESS SO THAT PEOPLE
WILL LOOK AT PUBLIC SERVICE IN
THE CAPITAL AS CONTINUING TO BE
A NOBLE CAUSE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
GOOD AFTERNOON WOMEN AND MEN OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE PAMELA LOPEZ
AND THE PRESIDENT OF WORK EQUITY
WHICH SEEKS TO EMPOWER THE
VOICES OF SURVIVORS.
IN THE FIGHT AGAINST SEXUAL
HARASSMENT WORK EQUITY KNOWS
THAT THIS WORK WAS DONE IN
EARNEST ANTI TAKEN WITH GREAT
SERIOUSNESS.
AND THAT ALL OF YOU THE MEN AND
THE WOMEN OF THIS COMMITTEE ARE
OUR ALLIES IN ADDRESSING SEXUAL
HARASSMENT NOT ONLY IN THE
CAPITAL BUT IN THE LARGER
CAPITAL COMMUNITY.
AND SO WE THANK YOU FOR THE
EFFORT AND INTENSITY THAT HAS
GONE INTO DEVELOPING WHAT ARE
REALLY EXCELLENT SET OF
RECOMMENDATIONS.
OF COURSE WE ALL HAVE TO WORK
TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE ENFORCED AND
THAT WE IS THE COLLECTIVE
COMMUNITY CHANGE OUR CULTURE. TO
STOP SEXUAL HARASSMENT BEFORE IT
BEGINS AND SO WORK EQUITY LOOKS
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALL OF
THE MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK COURSE
THE DEVIL IS ALWAYS IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND SO WE WILL BE
THERE TO SUPPORT EFFORTS TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT GOES RIGHT.
BUT THANK YOU AGAIN.
THANK YOU FOR THAT [inaudible]
ANY OTHER [inaudible]
PUBLIC TESTIMONY.
THEN -- TO
HAVE A MOTION.
DOES THIS MITCHELL UP LIKE TO
MAKE THE MOTIONS OF MISTER CHAIR
ANA AND FOR CLARITY I'LL READ --
THE MOTION INTO THERECORD
FAMILIES C. S. THANK YOU I MOVE
THAT THE JOINT RULES COMMITTEE
ONE APPROVED AND SENT TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON RULES IN
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON RULES.
THE RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
SUBCOMMITTEE ON SEXUAL
HARASSMENT PREVENTION RESPONSE
WITH THE FOLLOWING AMENDMENTS.
HEY IN RECOMMENDATION FOR SUBSET
SUBSECTION SO RECOMMENDATION A
BAD BEFORE THE LAST SENTENCE
QUOTE THE RULES COMMITTEE IF
EACH HOUSE WILL MAKE ITS
APPOINTMENT TO THE PANEL IN
QUOTE.
A RECOMMENDATION FIVE SUB
RECOMMENDATION A STRIKE THE
FOLLOWING LANGUAGE QUOTE THE
CHAIR OF THE RELEVANT RULES
COMMITTEE WILL RECEIVE A COPY OF
EACH REPORT.
AND AT QUOTE.
IN THE SENATE EACH.
REPORT SHALL BE SIMULTANEOUSLY
PROVIDED TO ALL FIVE MEMBERS OF
THE RULES COMMITTEE.
AND THE SECETARY OF THE SENATE
IN THE ASSEMBLY EACH REPORT
SHALL BE SIMULTANEOUSLY PROVIDED
TO THE CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR OF
THE ASSEMBLY RULES COMMITTEE AND
THE CHIEF ADMINISTRATIVE
OFFICER.
TO REQUEST THAT THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON RULES IN THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON RULES FOR THOSE
SUBCOMMITTEES TAKE APPROPRIATE
ACTION.
BEGIN IMPLEMENTING THE
RECOMMENDATIONS. THREE DIRECT
LEDGE COUNCIL TO BEGIN
ORGANIZING THE INDEPENDENT
WORKPLACE CONDUCT UNIT.
AND REQUEST ADVICE ON THE
LEGISLATIVE ACTS AS NECESSARY
FOR THE CREATION ADMINISTRATION
OF THE NEW UNIT.
AND THE INDEPENDENT PANEL. FOR
REQUEST THAT LEADERS IN BOTH
HOUSES ASK THE CHIEF JUSTICE OF
CALIFORNIA TO APPOINT THREE
PALACE TO SERVE IN THE
INDEPENDENT PANEL TO MAKE
FINDINGS AND RECOMMENDATIONS IN
RESPONSE TO COMPLAINTS IF
INAPPROPRIATE CONDUCT AFFECTING
PROTECTED CLASSES. FIVE ADOPT
THE SUBCOMMITTEES PROPOSED
BICAMERAL POLICY INAPPROPRIATE
WORKPLACE CONDUCT TO SUPERSEDE
EACH HOUSES POLICY ON SEXUAL
HARASSMENT. TO TAKE EFFECT ON
FEBRUARY ONE TWENTY NINETEEN OR
WHEN LEDGE COUNCIL AS HAS
ESTABLISHED A NEW WORKPLACE
CONDUCT UNIT.
AND BEAT REQUEST ASSISTANCE FROM
LEDGE COUNCIL TO IDENTIFY ANY
RECOMMENDED CHANGES TO THE
POLICY INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED
TO ADDITIONAL DETAILS REGARDING
THE PROCEDURES FOR THE NEW
COMPLAINT PROCESS [inaudible]
SECONDED BOB BY MS FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY FURTHER COMMENT.
THEN WE WILL OPEN THE ROLE WE
WERE KEEP TO ROLL OPEN UNTIL ALL
MEMBERS WERE PRESENT.
IN THE LATTER.
GROUP.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY HIGH
[inaudible]
SENATOR CANNELLA [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALDERON
[inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
CERVANTES [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM I DALLEY I'VE
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GALLAGHER GRAYSON [inaudible]
MAYES [inaudible]
THIS AREA [inaudible]
SPEAKER RENDON.
SENATE MEMBER SALAS.
WALDRON.
THEY KEEP.
PRO TEM ACTIONS [inaudible]
SENATOR BATES [inaudible]
BERRYHILL [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
LARA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
WIENER
.
I SEE EIGHTEEN THE MOTION PASSES
WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
ASSISTANCE ATTENTION
[inaudible]
YEAH YES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES
[inaudible]
MAYES I
YEAH.
PROTON.
PROTON MACHEN'S [inaudible]
ATKINS I
GALLAGHER I SENATOR
BATES.
BATES I THINK YOU SENATOR
.
SENATOR HILL.
SENATOR HILL HILL AYE
[inaudible]
SENATOR MONNING.
MONNING I THANK YOU SO
.
SOME REMEMBER CARILLO
[inaudible]
CARILLO I THAT MOTION IS PASSED
EYES TWENTY FIVE NO ZERO THIS
MADE IN THE SENATE ASSEMBLY
JOINT RULES COMMITTEE IS HEREBY
JR